what's going on guys this is rob and
it's halloween week here at comics
explained and so for the next seven days
i'm turning my channel into a spookfest
of awesome stories involving monsters
and ghouls starting with a classic story
of marvel zombies
now some of you long time followers may
be asking yourselves rob didn't you do a
video on marvel zombies last year well
the answer is yes but that video sucks
so i'm remaking it
having said that as we get into this
story i want to take a couple of minutes
to run over some elements of the army of
darkness and ash williams the reason why
is because this story will initially
pick up with ash and so while we don't
need a comprehensive explanation on his
character we do need to have at least a
surface understanding at the very least
so ash williams as you may know hails
from the army of darkness universe based
on the single greatest film ever made
the evil dead
one of the elements of this universe is
an object referred to as the
necronomicon ex mortis also called the
book of the dead depicted as a book
bound in human skin when used the
necronomicon has the power to summon a
demon entity that possesses the souls of
others
serving as the catalyst for the plot
behind evil dead and the following
sequels including army of darkness as
well as the comic book stories by
darkhorse and dynamite entertainment ash
williams shopped smart by shopping at s
mart but was also on a constant quest to
keep the book out of the hands of
individuals who would use it for
nefarious purposes as well as kill the
various individuals whose souls were
possessed
coming to a head in issues number 12 and
13 of army of darkness vol 1 ash
williams dies and finds himself standing
at the pearly gates to heaven initially
questioning whether he died or not while
the story came after the official marvel
zombies event what this did was serve as
a prequel to the marvel zombies in order
to flesh out some of the details that
were initially left ambiguous
and so picking up with issue number one
of marvel zombies versus army of
darkness which sees ash williams landing
on earth in a trash dumpster the story
opens by telling us that this is the day
of the first day of the end of the world
furthermore what we're also told is that
a dimensional gate had opened leading to
ash williams being dropped here in
addition to someone else now while the
story doesn't initially provide us with
all this information what it does is
make sense of things as we go on
after being set upon by a homeless woman
scrounging through the dumpster ash runs
her off by throwing an apple core at her
head
recalling bits and pieces of his
post-death experience that he had died
and went towards the light of what was
assumed to be heaven ash comes to the
belief that he has actually died and is
in heaven proper however after coming
across daredevil while he fights
thunderball a villain with super
strength known for using a ball and
chain ash attacks daredevil believing
him to be the literal devil himself
however before he can take action the
old homeless woman draws his attention
by stating that no matter where ash goes
he will never escape the necronomicon in
addition to this she provides a warning
in that this world will die and an army
of the dead will rise however because
this is ash and he doesn't take lift
from anyone including demons he punches
the old woman in the face and knocks her
out
using his chainsaw arm ash takes the
woman by the neck with the intention of
cutting her head off but after
witnessing this scuffle and believing
that ash is attacking an old innocent
woman daredevil intervenes by knocking
thunderball aside and attacking ash
intending to knock ash out but failing
to realize that thunderball is coming up
behind him daredevil's knocked into a
wall and falls unconscious after which
ash muses with thunderball for a few
minutes before believing him to be a
hero and the two go their own separate
way
and so after hearing the old woman's
prediction ash labors under the belief
that it has become his mission to save
this earth from what he believes is the
coming threat of deadites
reading a local newspaper and learning
that the avengers stand as the earth's
mightiest heroes he travels to their
mansion under the hope of recruiting
them as allies to his cause however once
he arrives instead of using the intercom
to summon the team peacefully he instead
shoots it with his boomstick with the
avengers answering his call albeit under
less than favorable terms ash finds
himself seized by luke cage with thor
bending his boomstick into a pretzel
with captain america ceasing hostilities
and having the avengers stand down ash
begins to explain that he was warned of
a coming apocalypse and that the
avengers along with the rest of the
world's heroes have to assemble for the
threat however all legitimacy of his
claim is thrown out the window when he's
asked how he came by this information
and states that he was told by a
homeless woman
from here the situation goes from bad to
worse when the avengers consider him
crazy and ash states that in his own
universe he had battled the deadites
which was a name used for possessed
souls and defeated them on multiple
occasions even when he found himself
confined to a mental institution and so
after hearing enough and considering him
to be a quack along with ash becoming
increasingly frustrated by the fact that
the avengers are laughing at him the
scarlet witch uses her magic to teleport
him away
landing in a lake which the scarlet
witch mused about sending him to in
order to cool him off the story also
shows jarvis informing the avengers that
an odd set of events are occurring in
midtown and so while expressing his
frustration over the fact that the
avengers didn't take him seriously ash
begins to recall what happened when he
presumably died when he had passed on
and was approaching the pearly gates he
was stopped by saint peter who informed
him that no chainsaws or weapons were
allowed beyond that point and while ash
joked about bringing his boomstick an
event took place off panel capturing his
attention as well as the attention of
everyone around him
believing that whatever happened in
heaven is also happening on earth ash
sets out into the city to warn whoever
will listen to him and so with the
avengers traveling to the source of the
aforementioned disturbance by way of
their quinjet the group spots ash
williams in the street yelling at the
top of his lungs like a crazy person
landing and investigating the situation
the scene is also drawn the arrival of
spider-man and so while ash hits on both
miss marvel and black widow and makes a
bit of progress captain america becomes
jelly and has spider-man take ash away
with spider-man asking about what
happened and why he's predicting the end
of the world ash reveals that when he
was standing at the gates of heaven the
century robert reynolds had appeared and
attacked everyone killing them all
using his boomstick to shoot the sentry
because he was so powerful the bullets
didn't do any damage and ash was knocked
out of heaven and into this alternate
version of earth and so transitioning
back to the avengers we find that the
disturbance in midtown was due to the
arrival of a zombified century who had
single-handedly taken out all of the
avengers
now to sidetrack for a second this is
particularly important and the reason
why is because as we'll see later on
this version of robert reynolds is from
another reality but is part of an
infinitely repeating causal loop created
by the watcher
furthermore after killing the entire
avengers team including miss marvel the
various members begin to reanimate with
an insatiable desire for human flesh and
start attacking innocent civilians on
the street
witnessing the events firsthand
spider-man travels back in it never to
rescue a civilian before things get out
of hand arguing that even if this does
mean the end of the world he's going to
do his best to ensure that no civilians
are harmed in addition to this to
spider-man this entire situation is
simply a ploy by some enemy and that in
his mind the avengers will eventually be
restored and that they won't want the
death of civilians on their conscience
however ash responds by stating that
whatever is happening here is
irreversible and that these versions of
the avengers can only be destroyed not
returned to normal however after
dropping off the woman and instructing
her to get to safety it's revealed that
spider-man had been chased by steve
rogers lunging from a rooftop and
attacking spider-man steve rogers bites
him on the shoulder and infects him with
a zombie virus resulting in ash williams
being dropped and landing in front of
luke cage miss marvel and hawkeye
now following this the story picks up in
marvel zombies vs army of darkness issue
number two with spider-man pretending to
be a zombie initially attacking hawkeye
and intending to bite into his head
spider-man is warned by black widow not
to do it because they all taste bad
however spider-man argues that he's the
one that had to carry ash williams
around and listen to his nonsense
furthermore when luke cage makes the
argument that there's a whole world for
them to consume spider-man counters by
stating that luke is right and because
of that allowing spider-man to consume
ash won't make any difference and so
after giving in the story transitions to
spider-man taking ash to a rooftop where
he reveals that the entire situation was
a ruse and the spider-man has not
transformed into a zombie instead the
events that ash was proclaiming are
coming true and the intention of peter
is to learn everything he can in order
to save both his loved ones as well as
protect the world furthermore peter
rationalizes that while others would
have transformed almost immediately his
powers seemed to be working overtime to
defeat the virus and so in the midst of
the chaos and realizing that the entire
situation seems to go from beyond
containment and has moved to survival
peter parker literally leaves ash on the
rooftop and takes off for his home in
order to ensure that aunt may and mary
jane are safe
following this the punisher makes his
way to the roof presumably having
followed spider-man and as ash yells
about how spider-man is supposed to
protect the innocent the punisher
responds by stating that in new york
city no one is innocent and so teaming
up together what's really cool about
this is that for the punisher the fact
that a zombie apocalypse is happening
and taking over the world is irrelevant
in the face of the fact that for him
there's still criminals that need to be
adequately punished and in truth this is
something that punisher comments on
during their conversation where ash
argues that he needs to find the
sumerian book of the dead in order to
stop the existing apocalypse and save
the world the punisher agrees to help so
long as ash helps him first traveling to
the home of the kingpin wilson fisk and
true punisher style frank hassell
refuses to listen to reason taking the
more logical road kingpin argues that
the situation being what it is regarding
the zombie pandemic and the end of
everything the concept of heroes and
villains doesn't exist anymore instead
it's about survival and if at all
possible containment however frank
castle ignores this and instead
unleashes holy hell on kingpin and his
crew by spraying them down with bullets
making the argument that in his mind
none of them were ever human to begin
with
and so turning to ash and honoring the
agreement of helping him to find the
sumerian book of the dead punisher hands
his weapons off to ash instructing him
to work as an assistant of sorts and
that because the street outside is
filled with zombies punisher intends to
kill all of them and whenever he runs
out of ammo ash will throw him what he
needs to continue the fire fight
busting open the doors and running out
guns blazing the punisher takes on
leader elektra ulysses claw and others
however when he calls for ash to throw
him some magazines we find that ash has
bailed out leading to punisher being
consumed by the zombie horde now what i
want to do here is i want to sidetrack
for a second by picking up with the
story marvel zombies dead days as a
story that was thrown in a few years
after the original marvel zombies event
dead day served to fill in the holes
between the start of the zombie outbreak
and the events that led to the end of
the world
picking up with spider-man following his
departure from ash we find him traveling
back to his home in an effort to check
on mary jane and aunt may finally the
two of them glued to the television
watching the news covering the zombie
apocalypse peter parker begins to
succumb to the zombie virus with mary
jane running to his side the virus
completely takes over leading to peter
attacking mary jane and so following
this aunt may re-enters the room with a
bottle of peroxide for peter's bite only
to find that he has killed mary jane and
is consuming her brain
instructing mae to run to the bathroom
and lock the door because he can't
control his desire to consume flesh the
story transitions to magneto and
asteroid m now what's really interesting
about this segment is that this is an
instance where an aspect of the story is
never explained
during the conversation between magneto
and his acolytes the indication here is
that they had set the century loose on
the world in an effort to eliminate a
large majority of the human populace and
allow the mutants to take over
however the virus infected
indiscriminately and has led to the end
of the world
now what we're going to find as we get
further into the story is that this is
never explained and the arrival of the
century was due to the actions of the
watcher but looking to make amends for
his actions magneto vacates asteroid m
in an effort to collect what heroes
remain and provide a safe haven
and so picking up in westchester new
york we find the xavier institute is
under attack from the canadian superhero
team alpha flight who have turned into
zombies furthermore we learned from
storm that charles xavier has been
killed and because destroying the brain
does not kill the zombies according to
cyclops the only thing they can do at
the moment is try to escape and survive
in addition to this the x-men appear to
be largely unaware of the zombie
outbreak happening in new york city as a
whole and that when magneto arrives
while he makes the claim this is a
global issue and the only attitude they
can take is kill or be killed
the reaction of kitty pride is one of
surprise regarding the global pandemic
transitioning back to ash following his
abandonment of the punisher while he's
running for safety with the various guns
he's received from frank castle he
stumbles upon dazzler as she's being
attacked by bucky barnes
putting a double barrel boomstick to the
back of his head ash helps bucky
understand the error of his ways by
blowing his head to pieces
spitting some mad game and offering
dazzler the opportunity to rest her head
on his shoulder ash also recounts his
experience with the deadites and saying
that during the events of evil dead army
of darkness and the subsequent stories
he was always able to attain the book of
the dead to defeat his enemy and send
them back to where they came from
using the same logic the argument he
presents to dazzler is that if he can
find the book of the dead in this
reality assuming that it exists he
should be able to end the apocalypse and
set everything back to normal
and so working together the two make
their way to greenwich village and the
home of dr strange the sorcerer supreme
however before they can arrive inside
the house and while dazzler explains who
doctor strange is a set of hands grab
ash and pull him into the shadows
realizing that he's not responding to
her questions dazzling turns around to
find that ash has been killed by a
zombie version of howard the duck
now jumping back to dead days we pick up
with ant-man hank pam using his giant
man form with black panther with the two
trying to escape a group of zombies and
hank leading to charlotte back to his
lab black panther comes to the
realization that pym's been bitten and
will eventually turn into a zombie
revealing the truth of his intention
hang pam recognized what it was that he
would become once he turned and intended
to kidnap black panther and use him as a
source of food by harvesting parts of
his body but because black panther is
aware that he's been bitten hank pym
grows into his giant man form knocks
black panther out and takes him back to
his lab
transitioning to the fantastic four in
the baxter building what marvel does is
cross some of the mainstream continuity
over into this alternate reality
continuity with she-hulk having
previously entered the backstreet
building and killed franklin and valeria
richards the idea here seems to be that
unlike the mainstream continuity
franklin did not have his reality
warping powers on the other hand like
the mainstream continuity she-hulk
served as part of the fantastic 4-4 time
and as such was able to gain entrance
using the access codes provided to her
when she was part of the team
and so using her powers to create force
fields susan storm avenges her children
by blowing she-hulk's head apart in
addition to this johnny storm informs a
group that they have an incoming call
from nick fury picking up with nick fury
himself we find an assortment of heroes
and villains gathered at the shield
helicarrier now in truth there's really
not a whole lot of meat and potatoes to
this part of the story this is really
just nick fury stating that everyone
needs to band together and create a
unified search effort for what's left of
humanity in addition to this what he
does is organize a plan with reed
richards tony stark and bruce banner
putting their minds together for the
purpose of developing a cure
now from here the story transitions to a
kind of montage with spider-man
attacking jay jonah jameson thor and ben
grimm assisting in the rescue party as
well as doctor doom declining the
request of nick fury to join the rescue
efforts and richard ryder being eaten by
zombies furthermore marvel began setting
the stage for the expansion of the
marvel zombie story by focusing on both
reed and tony stark individually in
terms of read susan storm visits him in
the midst of his autopsy of alpha
flight's vindicator keeping the trend of
reed focusing more on science than his
humanity his main focus during the
autopsy is that the zombie form is
actually more efficient biologically due
to the fact that they don't eat sleep
and use far less energy as the only part
of their bodies that remains functional
is the brain
now this is kind of a weird throw in
considering the fact that the zombie
superheroes are just as capable as they
used to be even though they're now
zombies and in truth the only reason
this is here is to establish the motives
for ree's actions later in the story and
so at this point we transition to tony
stark who's being visited by nick fury
while stark was tasked with creating a
cure in his mind even if they are
successful it would take decades for the
planet to recover and even then they may
never come back from this
as a result he's used various
technologies of reed richards to develop
a portal that can access another
dimension and his hope is that they can
find a reality much like their own that
is low in population waiting for
recovery from some kind of a disaster
but it's not infected by the zombie
horde and so because the situation is
this desperate rather than telling stark
to get back to work on a cure nick fury
allows him to continue working on a
means to escape
and so jumping back to the rescue
efforts the story picks up with the
x-men and while doing their best to save
the various humans and non-powered
heroes and villains wolverine is
attacked by hawkeye and steve rogers and
magneto does what he can to save off the
various zombies however because the odds
are so overwhelming magneto signals a
retreat with everyone traveling back to
the helicarrier now moving back to reed
richards and the fantastic four reid
states that before he brings his
findings to nick fury his investigations
have shown that the zombification of the
planet isn't so much about the ending of
the world as it is about evolution to
him humanity's violence has been a
constant part of society and the various
battles between heroes and villains was
a reflection of this primal nature of
humans and so the situation as it's
unfolding now is really more of people
being forced to cast off the illusion of
peace and revealing who they really are
as a result he had exposed the rest of
the fantastic four to the zombie virus
and in turn allowed them to attack him
at this point the story jumps back to
tony stark following his completion of
the portal device however the situation
is such that the portal can only be used
once due to the amount of power that
would be consumed by transporting all
the survivors both human and super
powered furthermore the timeline for the
transport of the survivors is limited
due to both how fast people are dying
and by extension how fast the zombie
ranks are expanding however before the
two can converse any further they're
attacked by reed richards and the rest
of the fantastic four
because tony stark can find his plan in
read in order to use his technology to
build the portal reed intends to use the
portal as a means to access other
dimensions and feed on the various
occupants
moving the portal to an elevator nick
fury recalls the remaining heroes
consisting of thor storm doctor strange
and others in addition to initiating
failsafe 30 which locks down the
building and sends the elevator to a
panic room
in addition to this unlike tony stark
fury argues that even if they were to
use the portal there would be no way to
ensure that the zombies would be unable
to repower it following their departure
as a result while the fantastic four
invades the panic room thor destroys the
portal on nephiri's orders to ensure
that no one can go from that reality to
another and so within the next couple of
minutes the fantastic four kill all the
remaining heroes who in turn transform
into zombies
now while this is happening the story
jumps to dazzler following the death of
ash and at this point the story goes
from campy to campier what marvel does
here is introduce a version of ash
native to this reality as opposed to the
version of ash from the evil dead
universe who was dropped into this
reality at the beginning of the story
when dazzler had partnered with the
original ash after they had arrived at
the home of doctor strange and that
version of ash had died the new ash had
killed howard the duck as he moved
towards dazzler however in the midst of
being awesome howard the duck resurfaces
due to the fact that ash had failed to
realize that shooting one of the zombies
in the head does not kill them and so
moments before meeting his demise the
scarlet witch appears and turns howard
into glass
knocking him down and causing him to
shatter into a million pieces the story
jumps to the inside of doctor strange's
home
interrogating the various books in turn
and burning the ones that refuse to
answer their question the trio finally
locate a dark arts book that will
provide the answers they seek
as it states since the necronomicon was
first discovered and translated by an
angel society looking to harness the
power of the damned various cults and
societies have looked to capture it and
use it for their own purposes
as a result while it fell out of contact
with the world and was lost from all
memory the book itself was eventually
located in the arcanum of dr doom and
latviria
at this point the story provides us with
an explanation of how it was that the
virus spread around the world so fast
when the virus initially broke out after
the century had attacked the avengers in
truth the zombie infection could have
been contained instead while shield was
working on a way to ensure of this the
scarlet witch had found herself
surrounded by zombies who intended to
consume her calling for help she was
eventually saved by her brother
quicksilver however scarlet witch was
actually revealed to have been mystique
in disguise because quicksilver
possessed such astonishing speed once he
was infected he was able to make quick
work of various individuals in new york
proper from there he sped across the
oceans and began infecting heroes
overseas including captain britain brian
braddock from england some russian hero
no one cares about the silver samurai
shin harada from japan as well as
various individuals throughout the
savage land in antarctica
and so picking up with the current
events the story transitions to ash
williams meeting doctor doom for the
first time
because doom doesn't understand how
awesome ash is he takes offense by being
referred to by nicknames like 3po mr
robotto and so on
backing off and addressing doom by the
name he deserves ash scarlet witch and
dazzler are taken below the castle to
the science wing where doom reveals that
the zombie infection of earth has
nothing to do with the necronomicon or
the deadites and instead is
extraterrestrial as a result in the mind
of doom the only way to defeat the
zombie threat is through magic not
sorcery furthermore the kingdom of
doomstat is protected by a mystical
force fuel that was created by doom and
is currently under siege by bill foster
a hero that managed to acquire the pym
particles that allow for a being to turn
into a giant person
attacking the castle doom repels and
destroys goliath by firing several
missiles into his chest and blowing them
up
and so following this doom reveals that
some of the occupants of liveria were
rescued from the zombie infection but
when he underwent the selection process
for who would be allowed to survive he
only chose those of breeding age and
adequate health as a result scarlet
witch and dazzler are allowed to dine
with doom while ash is sent below to be
held with the other survivors
following this the scarlet witch snuck
off and rescued ash by freeing him from
the pens with the intention of taking
him to the arcanum to verify his
information however because dim would
become aware that something was off ash
sends scarlet witch back to doom and
dazzler in order to keep him preoccupied
donning the clothing of one of the
doombots ash enters the arcanum and
attains the book of the dead while ash
questions the book with the intention of
finding a cure to the zombie plague the
necronomicon tells him that the zombie
outbreak has nothing to do with the
deadax or the necronomicon instead it
originates from another source of
unknown origin in addition to this the
prophecy of the old woman simply stated
that an army of the dead would rise not
an army of the deadites and so armed
with this information what marvel tells
us is that the zombie outbreak is in
effect completely incurable and after
learning the truth ash leaves the
arcanum in an effort to figure out a
solution and so as the situation comes
to a head doom stat falls under attack
by the combined forces of the x-men and
various superpowered zombies as hank
mccoy explains because normal humans
were consumed almost immediately after
the outbreak reed richards and the x-men
worked together to reprogram cerebro to
search for humans rather than mutants
discovering that a large supply was
housed within doomstat itself the x-men
seized on the castle using reed's
intelligence to circumvent the
protection that doom had instilled and
so traveling back to the arcanum ash
speaks with the necronomicon making the
case that because it's found in human
flesh and written in blood once the
human feud source of the zombies has run
out they will inevitably come forward
out of desperation
realizing that it would likely be
consumed the necronomicon agrees to help
ash escape the zombie plague as well as
attempt to bring it to an end
traveling to a transporter that doom had
designed for the purpose of expanding
his influence into other realities
because ash had distracted the zombies
during their battle and allowed doom the
opportunity to escape and send his
people to another dimension
doom allows ash to use a teleporter in
addition to this the portal is
programmed to alternate between
realities every five seconds meaning
that even if the portal weren't
destroyed the zombies would be unable to
enter and follow ash
traveling through ash finds himself
dropped into a reality composed entirely
of werewolf versions of the marvel
characters all of whom have been turned
into zombies and began chasing him
so getting into part two of our coverage
of the marvel zombies story what we're
told here is that at some point ultimate
reid had been contacted by an alternate
reality version of himself who had
intended to bring together the brightest
minds in the multiverse for an unknown
mission
as a result ultimate read had begun
production of a portal that could allow
transport to this alternate reality and
in turn allow its occupants to transport
to the ultimate universe
using the teleporter for the first time
ultimate reed lands in the zombie
universe amidst the ruins of the baxter
building
traveling through the streets and
finding the world virtually devoid of
all life reed comes face to face with
the zombified versions of himself and
the rest of the fantastic four
because a situation proves to be
overwhelming and ultimate reid is very
naive relative to his other self he
doesn't quite grasp the nature of the
situation and that he was lured here
because the zombies had simply run out
of food
fleeing for his life by coming face to
face with the various other zombies
within the zombie universe the group is
as much intrigued by reed as they are
interested in consuming him for a couple
of reasons the first is that they
initially don't know he teleported there
from another dimension leading them to
believe that there may be a supply of
humans still in existence on the planet
even after most were presumably
teleported away by dr doom
the second reason is because he looks
exactly like reed from the zombie
universe albeit younger which leads the
group to realize that he is from an
alternate reality meaning the
opportunity exists for them to leave
this universe in the pursuit of new food
however in the midst of their curiosity
and presumed intention of consuming reed
the group is suddenly set upon by a ton
of vehicles fleeing from the scene while
some are killed reed is met by the
arrival of magneto the last surviving
super-powered being on the face of the
earth
bringing reed to their hideout magneto
establishes that from the time the
century attacked the first hero to the
time that reed has just now arrived only
three days have passed during which all
but 12 humans were consumed by the
zombies in addition to this one of the
survivors a girl named kelly bridge
immediately takes up arms against reed
because of the fact that all of the
super powered beings minus magneto are
infected and because individuals like
mystique use shape-shifting as a way to
infiltrate human groups and consume them
kelly along with several of the other
survivors are weary of reed's presence
as he explains reed himself is from
another reality whereby the zombie
infection has not appeared while magneto
considers this to be a problem due to
the fact that the zombies have a way out
of this reality and into a new one at
the same time the possibility exists
that they can escape this universe and
take refuge in another one
however before they can leave the group
is attacked by thor and the avengers who
track them using wolverine's ability to
pick up sense
using his powers over magnetism magneto
throws a train at the group allowing
himself the humans and reed an
opportunity to escape
and so rather than finding refuge once
they get outside the group is met with a
host of zombified heroes and villains
including elektra beast storm and black
bolt of the inhumans and so in the midst
of attacking the group the various
zombies suddenly began writhing in agony
with hank pym declaring that he's been
blinded along with all of the other
zombies
making their presence known it's
revealed that susan storm ben grimm and
johnny had used the portal from the
ultimate universe to arrive in this
reality with susan having used her power
to create force fields in the zombie's
eyes causing them to go blind
using this opportunity to escape the
remaining four or five humans who
survived the attack as well as a
fantastic four prepare to leave by way
of the teleporter and while magneto is
offered the opportunity to leave as well
he decides to stay due to the fact that
someone needs to remain behind to
destroy the teleporter and ensure that
the zombies are unable to rebuild it and
make their way back through
now at this point the story picks up
with the actual five-part marvel zombies
event with magneto staying behind
following the departure of the ultimate
fantastic four we pick up with him
attempting to escape the zombie horde
leading them on a merry chase along the
way the acolytes magneto had left on
asteroid m at the start of the outbreak
are able to re-establish contact stating
that several of them had died when
various super-powered individuals had
attempted to invade
informing the group that his intention
is to make his way back to asteroid m
because the use of his powers to destroy
the portal was so exhausting and the
constant escape from the zombies hasn't
given him the chance to recover magneto
is unable to escape earth by traveling
directly through space
continuing to avert the zombies
magneto's location is discovered by
hawkeye who signals the rest of the
group
taking refuge in a construction site
marvel provides us with a literal last
man standing with magneto using his
powers to fend off the combined forces
of the zombies while handling his own
for a time in a moment of arrogance when
he challenges the zombies and declares
that they were foolish for attempting to
kill him in an area surrounded by steel
and concrete wasp transforms into her
full form and attacks magneto from
behind
succumbing to the infection magneto is
then consumed by the zombies which
officially means that all of the living
beings on the planet earth are
completely gone
from here the story jumps forward to the
arrival of the silver surfer heralding
the coming of galactus because he was
quite literally traveling through the
world at super speed the zombies don't
initially spot him but after several
glimpses of him traveling around the
world the group begins to spread out
furthermore because the human population
was believed to have been completely
wiped out it's revealed that hank pym
has actually been harvesting the limbs
of black panther as a way to keep his
hunger at bay while simultaneously
attempting to find a cure for the plague
however while in the midst of feasting
hank pam is suddenly set upon by wasp
who had been following him
becoming fed up with her nonsense rather
than slapping her across the face
instead hank pym simply bites her head
off
picking back up with the rest of the
group the silver surfer makes his
appearance known by declaring that the
planet will soon be met with the arrival
of galactus the devourer of worlds but
instead of panicking and running for the
hills the zombies immediately attack the
silver surfer where we would normally
believe that the silver surfer could
easily repel the zombies due to his
possession of the power cosmic and the
vast abilities that it provides because
of the sheer number of zombies attacking
the surfer he's completely overwhelmed
and as a result the zombies consume him
which in turn provides all of them with
an equal share of the power cosmic
at the same time that this is happening
black panther had come too and seized
the opportunity to patch himself up and
make an escape along with the severed
head of wasp
now where the marvel zombies story is
largely action with little room for
interpretation the conversation between
wasp and black panther is actually one
of the most important parts of this
story the reason why is because this
sets the stage for a way to end the
zombie plague without actually curing
the zombies as she explains the desire
for the consumption of flesh is
all-consuming and her body physically
aches because of her need for flesh but
as black panther points out the fact
that she's disembodied indicates that
the pain that she experiences from a
lack of consuming flesh is largely
psychological however before the
conversation can continue any further
black panther is met by the arrival of
fabian cortez a mutant with the ability
to enhance the powers of other mutants
as well as the rest of the acolytes at
this point we transitioned to the
arrival of galactus intending to consume
the planet in order to satisfy his
hunger after asking the zombies what had
happened to his herald the silver server
ant-man simply responds that they ate
him and so using their newly acquired
power cosmic to attack galactus and
attempt to consume him the zombies are
repelled with little effort from
galactus himself
now retreating and taking time to form a
plan the story transitions to black
panther again following his discovery by
the acolytes with magneto missing but
presumed dead the acolytes arrived on
earth led by fabian cortez for the
purpose of investigating what it was
that had happened to magneto and why he
never reported in
because black panther looks worse for
wear after being harvested for his limbs
and because those with superpowers
sustain themselves even after being
infected the acolytes believe that he's
a zombie with one of the members
attacking him black panther defends
himself by throwing the severed head of
janet van dyne at his assailant as well
as doing what he can to fight physically
however before the conflict gets too far
cortez steps in and forces his men to
stand down
now this is in stark contrast to the
fabian cortez of the normal marvel
continuity and that to fabian black
panther and the acolytes represent
what's left of humanity because of this
if they are to survive they have to work
together instead of fighting and that
the demise that his fellow members met
with was a result of their own actions
with black panther simply fighting to
protect himself
now transitioning back to the zombies we
learned that following their retreat
from galactus ant-man and several others
had left for several days in an effort
to find a way to defeat galactus and
consume him
in addition what marvel does here is
provide us with a little insight into
the zombies themselves and how they
function in this new world according to
spider-man when he's asked by luke cage
why he continues to wear his mask
despite everything that's going on
peter replies that after eating his aunt
and mary jane he can't bear to look at
himself in the mirror now what this does
is set the early stage for the events
that we'll see in marvel zombies 2 which
will see a civil war among the various
characters but it also tells us that
despite everything that's happened the
zombification of peter and the others
hasn't really destroyed who they are
instead it allows him to maintain their
overall identities while simultaneously
driving them to consume flesh
and so with wolverine arriving and
informing the two that ant-man reed and
the others have returned we learned that
during the days in which they were
hiding out and in order to satisfy their
hunger for flesh the group has quite
literally been digging into their own
stomachs pulling out the digestive
remains of the silver surfer and
re-eating them
furthermore the reason for ant-man and
the others leaving was to gather
vibranium from wakanda some unidentified
materials from castle doom and the
baxter building as well as several
crystals from dr strange's sanctum
sanctorum
while we don't initially know what these
were for the reason for acquiring these
items becomes apparent when the group
assembles them into a device that i
don't recognize and attacked galactus
with it however because the actions of
galactus assembling the world destroyer
device has drawn the attention of
multiple zombified heroes and villains a
battle breaks out between the group over
ant-man's team putting in the work to
defeat galactus versus the heroes who
have arrived and laid claim to it
descending into a miniature civil war
what marvel's doing here is basically
thinning out the herd as a way to scale
down on the focal characters of the
story
as an example while eddie brock is still
in possession of the venom symbiote as
he explains after being infected by the
zombie virus the symbiote itself is
dying and seems to have been
biologically incompatible with eddie
following his infection
where marvel leaves this a little
ambiguous the overall theme is that
eddie brock ends up dying after being
attacked by spider-man and so while the
battle is relatively short-lived in the
end ant-man states that consuming
galactus is more important than fighting
the other zombies as a result the group
uses the power cosmic to kill the
remainder of the zombies and turn their
attention to consuming galactus
now at this point this story jumps
forward by five years
with black panther and the acolytes
returning marvel drops a massive bomb in
the form of wasp as a group travels
throughout the planet we learn that at
some point during this five-year period
ant-man zombies had left the earth after
consuming galactus furthermore wars
established that the zombies don't die
of starvation the current form of wasp
reveals that after a certain amount of
time has passed the hunger goes away
which tells us that it is entirely
psychological now while this bit of
information with black panther the
acolytes and wasp is short what the
story does is transition to an unnamed
race on the far side of the universe
with the various scientists reporting to
what appears to be the king we learn
that the race is expecting the arrival
of galactus who has been cutting a swath
through the universe consuming worlds
left and right
picking up with his arrival we find the
galactus is actually ant-man's zombie
group who have been feeding on the
inhabitants of countless planets across
the cosmos
so as we continue our final video on
marvel zombies what we do now is we pick
up with the second half of marvel
zombies 2
as well as marvel zombies return but
before we get into that i want to have a
quick discussion on the ultimate
universe
covered in issues 30-32 in truth this
story isn't really important it's
largely confined to the zombie version
of the fantastic four after their
capture at the hands of doctor doom but
the story is really more of a one-off
and in a lot of ways has no real bearing
on the main marvel zombie story and so
much to the chagrin of some fans i'm
actually going to skip over this instead
we're going to jump into marvel zombies
2 which picks up 40 years after the end
of marvel zombies 1 and ant-man's group
traveling throughout the universe
as the story opens up we learn that
during this period of time all
non-powered beings in the universe have
been consumed and that those who have
powers have been transformed into
zombies including thanos gladiator of
the shiar empire and phoenix as a result
the problem they face is that with
nothing left to consume the hunger they
suffer from and the pain that comes with
it is unbearable and so as expected
various zombies begin turning on each
other the first of which are thanos and
the hulk
arguing that hulk had eaten twice as
much as he should have leading to the
food supply being depleted twice as fast
thanos and hulk began fighting one
another with iron man attempting to get
the two to stop
after smashing thanos head and
obliterating it in the process the hulk
states that he had entered the conflict
and that from that point forward he was
going to be eating his own supply of
food as well as thanos
sounds weird in addition to this because
gladiator is relatively new to his life
as a zombie and because the hunger is so
overpowering in his desperation he
begins to eat the zombified thanos
despite being aware of how bad other
zombies taste and the fact that
consuming them does not satisfy the
hunker that they suffer from
as a result ant-man and iron man make
the case that since stark had been
working on a portal to another dimension
prior to being transformed into a zombie
the group could travel back to earth
figure out a way to rework the portal
and use it to jump to another reality
where they can feed on a fresh supply of
food
and so transitioning back to earth
proper during the period where the
zombies were away black panther the
acolytes and wasp had begun the process
of providing a safe haven for the group
to survive
where we would expect them to make the
effort of repopulating the earth during
his conversation with forge it's
revealed that while black panther had
married lisa hendricks who was one of
the acolytes but turned from the group
because she is the only woman as all the
remaining survivors are men the
community lacks the gene pool to
actively procreate in addition to this
the group faces a problem on two fronts
because the gene pool is limited the
complete extinction of humanity is
almost guaranteed and that a time will
come when the lack of viable offspring
will lead to no more humans being born
and the second is that because of this
situation the acolytes as they're being
led by the son of the now dead fabian
cortez have been plotting against
t'challa with the intention of rising up
against him and taking the throne
while wasp's time among the group has
allowed her to overcome her hunger and
serve as a viable member of the
community
due to their looming extinction she has
on multiple occasions offer the option
of biting them and transforming them
into zombies however in the eyes of
black panther and the rest of the
community this is an option that they
have no desire to entertain
and so all of these themes come to a
head when one of the acolytes sneaks
into the bedroom of t'challa and
mortally stabs him with wasps coming to
the rescue and killing the assassin
lisa's pleas for wasp to find a way to
save t'challa result in wasp biting him
in order to turn him into a zombie and
keep him alive
transitioning to a couple of days later
in an effort to help t'challa cope with
his hunger as well as force wasps to
cope with her re-emerging hunger after
biting black panther the two have been
confined to a cell on asteroid m
now the conversation between the two
isn't particularly important here and in
truth largely searched to demonstrate
the personal struggle of black panther
in that with his grandson outside of the
prison door he isn't quite sure as to
whether or not he actually wants to eat
him but the undercurrent of the acolytes
attempting to subvert the rule of black
panther comes when we learn that malcolm
the son of fabian cortez
is attempting an insurrection in
t'challa's absence
where forge attempts to talk malcolm
down and make an argument that the
revolution would only result in
malcolm's death following the return of
black panther in the eyes of malcolm
when the settlement was originally
launched t'challa and fabian had battled
over the position of leader and while
the people chose black panther the fact
that he's a zombie even with his full
faculties means that he's not capable of
leaving the people effectively again
following this banning together with a
zombified hawkeye and another scientist
forge travels to asteroid m to free wasp
and t'challa but because the acolytes
have completely taken over the
settlement and black panther would be
eliminated on site he and wasp take to
the surrounding area for several months
while malcolm and his elk are dealt with
before they can leave however and in the
midst of sneaking into the community and
gathering their belongings the entire
group is met with the return of the
zombie ant-man and his group
with wasp and black panther doing their
best to demonstrate that the hunger
ant-man and his group suffer from is
completely psychological
the hulk refuses to listen and instead
begins attacking and consuming various
people however ant-man steps in and
states that the problem that they had
before was that they ran through the
entire population of the universe
mindlessly with no thought of what would
happen when they finished instead of
making the same mistake these last
remnants of humanity could be turned
into a breeding pool and serve as an
infinite source of food effectively
giving them all a chance to start over
but after hearing ant-man's speech
spider-man turns against the group
arguing that they were heroes once now
where ant-man is okay with traveling
through the universe and consuming
everything peter is unwilling to allow
this to happen and instead turns against
the rest of the zombies turning to
reynolds one of the scientists loyal to
black panther he initiates a previously
developed force field to keep the
zombies out and keep the humans safe but
as the shield goes up gladiator is
revealed to have been confined inside
the force field along with the other
humans now where black panther and
spider-man plead with gladiator not to
attack the humans by preying on his
previous role as the honorable protector
of the shiar empire the motives of
gladiator are revealed when he states
that spider-man and his group had
consumed the shiar and that his
intention here is nothing more than
basic revenge by consuming what's left
of humanity and so while gladiator
attacks black panther wasp and
spider-man forge emerges in one of his
old iron man armors and is able to
subdue gladiator long enough for
spider-man to use his power cosmic and
disintegrate gladiator in the process
revealing his identity to tony stark
because forge is a mutant with an
intuitive ability to develop and enhance
machinery he's been spending the last 40
years improving on everything that sark
had been working on now while he's not
necessarily as smart as tony stark in
the end he was able to build on the
original iron man armor well enough to
go toe-to-toe with the zombies now where
ant-man and his group retreat back to
the backstreet building in order to
locate the portal that was used allowing
reed from the ultimate universe to
travel to this reality we learned that
at some point during the 40-year period
forge had taken the portal for the
purpose of rebuilding it after magneto
had destroyed it in an effort to use it
as a final escape from this universe but
as spider-man explains this decision is
a terrible one and that the portal was
the reason the zombies had come back to
earth in the first place
furthermore reynolds reveals that in
order to defeat the zombies they'll need
someone who can rally and organize their
efforts to this end during their
explorations in the surrounding area
reynolds and others had stumbled upon a
portion of a brain which was revealed to
have belonged to steve rogers
placing the brain in the body belonging
to the deceased son of black panther in
truth because the brain is incomplete
the new steve rogers basically just
spouts nonsensical one-liners about
rallying their efforts and fighting in a
war that doesn't exist
and so with the zombies returning and
confronting t'challa's team black
panther puts up a ruse by offering a
deal
if they hand over the portal to ant-man
and his team they'll use it to leave
this reality and travel to a new one
where they can feast on that universe's
occupants
accepting the deal black panther orders
the force field to be lowered after
which it's revealed that the entire
situation was a trick when black panther
wasp spider-man hawkeye and luke cage
all attack phoenix wolverine ant-man
iron man and fire lord with iron man
tapping into the force field and
allowing himself to pass through it
black panther's team is left out in the
open with no means of retreat while
stark makes his way into the facility
however upon arriving inside starks met
with the combined efforts of the new
steve rogers forge in the old iron man
armor as well as malcolm's acolytes and
the others
now while in the middle of battling
black panther's team and overcoming them
ant-man and his group managed to make
their way into the rest of the camp but
as he prepares to chow down on lisa
hendricks pym realizes that his hunger
is actually gone
pleading with wolverine to stop and for
everyone to gain their bearings iron man
arrives followed by a babbling colonel
of america who reveals that the hunger
is dissipated due to the fact that it's
been so long since they consumed anyone
rather than continuing the trend of
killing humans and eating them instead
ant-man proposes the option of taking
the time to rebuild instead of
destroying but in the midst of this
proposal the hulk shows up in the worst
possible state pissed off and hungry
with phoenix flying in to attempt to
stop the hulk she does what she can by
using her powers to launch an attack by
setting him on fire and in response hulk
punches a hole through her stomach and
afterwards smashes her head going on the
defense iron man ant-man and the new
colonel america attempt to take the hulk
down but they're all defeated in turn
with the hulk stepping on tony stark
smashing his guts into bits
because wasp was previously defeated and
disembodied reynolds comes out of hiding
by arguing that with wasp gone he has
nothing to live for anymore sacrificing
himself to stave off the hulk in the
midst of eating reynolds hulk's hunger
calms down long enough for him to
transform back into his bruce banner
form
because the hook persona emerges each
time banner becomes hungry he pleads
with ant-man and the others to kill him
while he's in his human form
granting his request the group uses
their power cosmic to destroy the head
of bruce banner which ultimately kills
him
and so transitioning to three weeks
later the story shows ant-man bringing
together the surviving characters as he
explains the lack of a diverse gene pool
means that within a few generations
everyone will have died out looking to
correct this problem hank pym forge and
several others had come together for the
purpose of rebuilding the portal however
before we can continue with an
explanation of their intentions malcolm
interrupts revealing that the reason
forge was unable to get the portal to
work before was due to the fact that he
would remove several key components that
were required for operation for malcolm
despite the fact that this is a
dystopian wasteland society is small and
manageable furthermore in order to
attempt to secure his position as leader
of the community he had previously
killed black panther's son in order to
eliminate the line of succession and so
as the story ends malcolm uses the
portal to send all the zombies away to
another dimension proclaiming that the
zombies are now someone else's problem
now what this does is it picks up with
marvel zombies return and in truth the
purpose of this story was to wrap
everything up and actually presents us
with the origin of the zombie plague and
the reason why is due to the fact that
following the events of marvel zombies 2
everything spun out into a series of
events following other characters and
were largely considered to be
nonsensical as a result marvel's lobby's
returns ignores much of the information
between marvel zombies 2 and everything
else and so for the sake of our
discussion we're going to do the same
thing
as the story opens we pick up with the
watcher who provides us with a run over
of the events from the first marvel
zombie story and that the century had
appeared on earth 2149 began to consume
the various heroes initiated the zombie
plague and effectively killed the world
and so using his technology to scour the
multiverse in search of where the
zombies have been sent his efforts come
to fruition when he locates spider-man
in the earth z universe
transitioning to the perspective of
peter parker he comments on the fact
that he's been transported to a new
world and even makes references to
malcolm sending him away after getting
his bearings by reading a local
newspaper marvel establishes that in
addition to being sent to another
dimension spider-man has been sent into
the past furthermore the events taking
place in this time regarding the kingpin
and others working to collect an
artifact lead peter parker to believe
that in this reality he's still in
college and the events appear to be
transpiring the exact same way as they
did in the marvel main continuity and so
in the midst of the sinister six
launching an attack against the empire
state university while zombie spider-man
intervenes because so many humans are
gathered in one place his desire for
flesh becomes overwhelming and in the
process begins to attack and eat craven
the hunter with mysterio panicking due
to the fact that peter has never acted
this way before he begins casting
illusions of himself while attempting to
do peter into believing that he won't
know which one is which but using a
zombie spider cinch which searches for
meat instead of danger peter's able to
detect the real mysterio from the fake
one and in doing so immediately attacks
him by pulling his brain out through his
helmet
and so after attacking the rest of the
sinister six and consuming all of them
in turn the only one left standing is
sandman since his molecular structure
keeps peter from being able to consume
him fleeing for his life he eventually
comes across the peter parker native to
this universe who had discovered the
disturbance and intended to intervene
because sandman is unable to determine
which version of spider-man is real and
which one is a zombie he attacks this
reality's version of peter by entering
his body through his mouth
exploding outwards peter parker is
killed and his guts and everything spill
out onto the street below
and so transitioning back to the watcher
as he's monitoring the situation because
the zombies were simply transported
throughout the multiverse with no idea
where they went the watcher contacts his
counterparts to inform them of what's
taking place
however before he can take any action
ant-man appears and bites him in half
stating that with the watcher's
technology at his disposal he now has
access to every version of earth in the
multiverse
at this point we pick up with tony stark
as he appears on this reality where the
mainstream continuity saw him recovering
from his alcoholism well enough to
return to a life of normalcy in this
reality the events of demon in a bottle
never ended and stark industry has
fallen into a state of disrepair
during one of his hangovers he's met
with happy hogan where we learn that a
dimensional intrusion alarm has gone off
initially intending to check in on his
own tony stark is turned down by happy
who investigates in his place and
immediately after arriving at the
disturbance he encounters ant-man who
promptly bites him in half
transforming into a zombie he begins
staggering through the facility and
eventually comes across james rhodes and
a few others
attempting to attack them while he is
able to kill one of the office workers
james rhodes shoots him in the head
while simultaneously calling for backup
however as we learn ant-man has been
busy and most of the facility is overrun
with zombies is fallout from his various
attacks
furthermore because pepper potts does
work directly under tony stork and
because she offers to use the iron man
armor in his place
the problem is that during his drunken
state he doesn't know where he put the
armor in addition to this the
dimensional monitoring device tony had
acquired from reed richards had alerted
him what was going on and while he
dismantled it in an effort to turn it
off the problem is that he doesn't know
how to reassemble it and so with the
facility being overtaken and the zombies
running rampant throughout the building
pepper potts pleads with stark to do
something at which point he goes into a
hidden vault and pulls out his prize
bottle of alcohol
jumping back to james rhodes as he
attempts to escape the zombies chasing
him during which time he discovers the
iron man suit left there by tony stark
intending to take it to tony so he can
don the armor and save them once he
reaches stark's office he finds him
stumbling around drunk with pepper being
attacked
using the armor to blast the zombie we
learned from tony stark that he had
apparently forgotten to charge it the
last time he had used it and as a result
it's completely out of power and so with
pepper succumbing to her injuries and
transforming into a zombie herself
due to having consumed so much alcohol
tony stark pukes all over the front of
her however rather than continuing to
attack him she flees in fear as her face
begins to melt away after which is
revealed the tony had been drinking
alcohol but it contained millions of
nanites designed to cure cancer by
destroying the cells and when he spewed
it on pepper the nanites viewed the
zombie plague as a virus and as such
consumed her skin
and so as the two continue to discuss
the events stark says that if they're
going to save the world they'll need to
charge the suit so roadie can use it and
when the question is asked why stark
won't be using the armor he states that
he's having a final drink with some of
his friends at which point he's attacked
by several zombies
at the same time that this happens
though we also discovered that the
reason why ant-man arrived at stark
industries was to locate the dimensional
device star could receive from reed
richards as it would allow hank pym to
access the multiversal technology of the
watcher
now at this point marvel jumps forward
in time again and establishes two main
ideas the first is that while ant-man
and spider-man had been transported to
earth following their exile from the
previous zombie universe by malcolm the
others like black panther and wasp were
teleported to the shia home world among
other places and so banning the
universe's strongest races together they
launched an attack against the zombies
of earth in an effort to save the
universe ultimately however they proved
to be unsuccessful
in addition to this hank pym has
remained on the moon in an effort to
crack the code of the watcher's
interdimensional technology and allow
the new zombies the ability to travel
the multiverse and consume other
realities but because the technology is
so advanced and designed explicitly to
keep even the smartest individuals from
being able to hack it ant-man has
tethered together the brains of the
world's smartest men in an effort to use
their intelligence as a way to boost his
success from here the events pick up
with the zombies using the mind of
charles xavier to reveal that there are
humans on the planet who have escaped
into the savage land in antarctica
using their quinjet to investigate the
group is shot down by an unknown source
revealing the assailants marvel
establishes that the shots were fired
from james rhodes using the iron man
armor and fighting alongside the
incredible hulk spider-man and wolverine
as we learned the incredible hulk turned
against the sentry due to the fact that
during the collapse of the world the
hulk had turned back into his human form
at which point century had tried to kill
him and so engaging in a massive battle
with one another wolverine and century
begin going head-to-head
during their fight however wolverine
uses his claws to punch a hole through
this sentry leading to his power of a
million exploding sons attempting to
surge out from his body
at this point hank pam uses the power of
the watcher's technology to teleport
reynolds to the watcher's base revealing
that the reason he was unable to power
the interdimensional technology before
was due to a lack of energy him states
that with the century's body punctured
he can harness the inevitable eruption
of that energy and in turn allow the
marvel zombies to access the multiverse
shortly afterwards however wolverine
spider-man iron man and the hulk
teleport to the watchtower having
brought along a canister
throwing it at ant-man the canister is
revealed to contain the sandman flint
marco as we're told when tony stark
developed the nanites capable of eroding
diseased flesh the problem they ran into
was that in order for the nanites to
work they had to be exposed to the
interior of the human body
using wolverine's healing factor and
combining it with flint marco's blood a
vaccine was created that would allow
flint to carry the nanites without
having to worry about dying himself
dispersing the sand among all the
zombies flint is successfully able to
end the zombie attack by having the
nanites attack and break down their
flesh
and so with the sentry still confined to
his tube the watcher appears stating
that while ant-man had eaten him in the
beginning of the story he and his race
had achieved the ability to create a
disembodied form of themselves over the
course of their lifespan
now while this is clearly a shoehorn
attempt by marvel to end the story the
fact remains that the watcher uses his
technology to send the sentry back in
time to the original zombie dimension
thereby creating an infinite loop that
never ends with the sentry starting the
original outbreak leading up to the
current events seen here now to
sidetrack for a second here what this
does is create a ridiculous paradox and
the reason why is because if the sentry
was the person that originally started
the outbreak and then the events
transpired leading up to the current
situation right now then how was it that
the sentry was ever infected in the
first place but the unfortunate part of
this is that as mind-boggling as this is
marvel never answers this question
instead they just end the story here and
call it a day
okay so we are getting into marvel
zombies resurrection here's the thing
though recently marvel renamed it from
respawn to resurrection i don't know
where this takes place at like i don't
know if it takes place in the main
marvel universe i don't know if it takes
place in like an alternate reality and
i've googled all over the place and i
can find no indication of where this
story takes place as best as i can tell
it's a reboot basically of like the the
whole marvel zombies concept uh but i
don't i don't know where the i mean i
have a hard time believing it takes
place like in continuity in marvel but i
could be wrong maybe somebody has found
something that i haven't but i haven't
been able to find anything that
indicates that's the case instead what
we end up doing here is basically
picking up at the headquarters of the
fantastic four and the reason why and
this is why things are kind of
interesting here is because what's
happened is reed richards has basically
called together the illuminati but
notice this steven strange isn't here
right so that's kind of an indication
that it does not take place in the main
marvel universe although we don't know
really explicitly but regardless the the
way this kind of goes down is is reid
richards basically tells all these guys
who are here that what ended up
happening is they essentially that he
basically picked up a deep space message
from carol danvers who basically sat on
an sos right she's like everything's
going crazy and like there's something
here but but the whole message was kind
of garbled and sort of broken up but it
was impossible to tell exactly what it
was that she was referencing but all
reed richards got was basically this
image that galactus is out in space and
that galactus appears to be dead now
when this happens all the members of the
illuminati almost begin to panic and
rightfully so right like we've only seen
a couple instances where galactus has
died like for example there was one
instance where galactus died and then we
got abraxas kind of this representation
of the multiverse destruction he was a
super powerful entity that basically
jumped from one universe to the next
killing every version of galactus that
he found right we did a video on it and
you'll find that video down in the
description uh but there's there's
different things that kind of come out
of it but the big thing about this is
the amount of power it would take for a
being to successfully kill galactus is
is astronomical right it would have to
be something equal to him meaning like
celestials or something like that or
greater but because of the fact that
galactus is a cosmic entity meaning that
he serves a particular purpose and no
celestial or really cosmic entity out
there would kill galactus because he's
an essential force in the universe what
this means is it was a non-cosmic entity
that basically killed him and that's why
they're kind of panicking here that's
why they're kind of freaking out is
because what they're coming to the
realization of is that some being out
there this humanoid in nature whether
it's an alien or whatever the case is
was powerful enough to destroy galactus
and that really begs the attention of
everybody more so than that the big
concern is that because galactus was so
capable because he's so old because his
power is so vast and because those
individuals who can harness his ability
will in turn gain access to the power
cosmic to say nothing of the technology
that he has on his ship they basically
panic and say we gotta get out there and
basically get as much stuff as we can
before anybody else gets their hands on
it now it's interesting because it's
easy to look at that from like a
villainous perspective right like all
right guys galactus apparently he's dead
okay let's go just like plunder his
corpse
let's go plunder his remains before
anybody else does uh because we don't
want to be left with the leftovers we
want to get the good stuff up but that's
not really the case it's one of these
things where there's a lot of different
enemies out there it's one of the things
that is easy to forget in marvel comics
there's a lot of races out there that
would love to destroy humanity or
conquer the universe and using the power
of galactus they could conceivably do
that right and so because that what ends
up happening is by virtue of beast and
captain america as well as reed richards
of the fantastic four uh the x-men the
the avengers and the fantastic four come
together as a singular team now this is
not the full contingent of the x-men and
it's certainly not the full contingent
of the avengers right there's like four
avengers who are here there's a
smattering of x-men who are here but
it's basically a pretty heavy hitting
team right i mean you got magneto you've
got iron man you guys are pretty heavy
hitters you know here people who are
basically able to to put some
significant punches you have four
different things like that and so the
result of this is that as they begin to
get closer and closer to the location
what they end up doing is is basically
realizing that galactus is actually dead
where it was kind of believed that maybe
he's alive or maybe he's just kind of
unconscious or he was heading to earth
or whatever the case is given the
trajectory the indication is that he was
heading towards earth and for whatever
reason he stopped once they get here
they realize galactus is definitively
dead right galactus is basically out of
the picture here and so following this
it really turns into kind of a
reconnaissance mission it's really what
it turns into right let's get in here
let's see what's going on let's see what
it was that killed him and let's kind of
let's figure things out and go from
there now of course wolverine being here
is one of the first people to basically
realize that there's somebody else there
but they don't really know the full
extent of it right it's just kind of
like okay something seems a little off
here the reality is that the overall
situation seems a little off right the
whole thing seems a little murky but at
the end of the day it really is reading
them trying to solve this mystery and
trying to figure out what's going on and
so as a result of that as time begins to
pass what ends up happening is the
groups are basically split into sections
right reed richards and his guys
basically stay behind they kind of track
down what's going on with galactus and
all that kind of stuff iron man of
course stays there and a couple other
people and then from there you have the
x-men which is basically wolverine and
magic and maybe one or two other people
who go and investigate and then you have
the avengers who go in and investigate
as well right so everybody's kind of
splitting up into groups and going to
see what's going on the problem with
this is that once they get out there
they're basically met by somebody
wolverine begins to panic and everybody
else just seems to kind of be like what
the heck is going on and so what they
end up doing is realizing that what
happened with galactus at least what
seems to be going on here is that
galactus has in effect been hollowed out
that what's taking place here is
somebody somewhere killed galactus and
then basically hollowed him out in such
a way and began to channel his energy
throughout his body so that it could be
used as basically kind of like a
makeshift ship now that's not the first
time that we've seen that and it's one
of the cool things about how this gets
done right for those of you guys who
remember the thanos imperative story for
example we had the cancer verse and
inside that universe galactus had
basically been been destroyed and what
this led to was the creation of what was
called the galactus engine right this
massive engine of destruction so we've
seen stories where galactus has been
defeated in some form or fashion and
then repurposed by various people and
then used for a particular cause so it's
not the first time we've seen something
like this and it's actually pretty
interesting but what we end up realizing
is this mystery person that the x-men of
the avengers were talking to was none
other than carol danvers herself and
this is important and the reason why is
because what we end up learning is that
this was that that distress signal that
was sent out to read richards was sent
by this zombified version of carol the
other thing that goes on here and this
is kind of crazy about this this is what
sort of throws me off is wolverine makes
reference to remembering her now in
terms of him saying like i remember you
it's not like i remember you you're
carol danvers that's that's not what
he's referencing it's i remember you you
zombie type person you and that's why i
say it kind of throws me off on where
this takes place right because at the
end of marvel zombies return when they
were when they were in earth z
spider-man basically tried to find a
cure for the the zombie plague and then
took uh took uh wolverine's body with
him and then i don't think we ever found
out what happened to it and so it's
entirely possible that this takes place
in like an alternate universe or
something along those lines where
wolverine was taken by spider-man he was
cured and then dumped here maybe we
don't really know exactly what it is
that's going on we don't know how these
zombies got here i mean it is only the
first issue so there's probably a lot of
explanation and a lot of extrapolation
coming out of it the issue with this is
that wolverine basically panics right so
the fact that he knows who carol danvers
is and he recognizes this zombie concept
basically tells him to tell you he tells
everybody get out of here everybody run
get out of here as fast as you possibly
can and of course wolverine is set upon
by these these you know by the ciara the
scrolls the whole nine yards but what
we're what we're really looking at here
and what seems to be the case is that
whatever place these zombies hail from
they're all inside galactus right they
all use galactus body to get here now it
could be it was used as a as kind of a
dimensional jump right and we've seen
that before too that's one of the cool
things about this is galactus has been
used for a lot of purposes those are
guys who were who don't know what i'm
talking about uh during jonathan
hickman's run on the fantastic four what
he did is there was a segment in the
story where he basically gave those gave
us the future of the old man logan
universe and what ended up happening in
that future of old man logan which i
don't think is really in continuity
anymore but what ended up happening in
that future is ultimately uh earth was
kind of liberated for lack of a better
word by all the various villains who had
risen up and taking control of
everything and so hulk jr the the baby
version of the incredible hulk that old
man had old man logan had rescued at the
end of the story basically grew up to
have his own superhero team the issue
with that is earth was essentially
coming to a close it was it was
basically going to be destroyed and so
when galactus arrived to consume it
ultimately galactus was defeated and
then his body was used as a means to
essentially jump out of that dimension
and into the main marvel universe so
we've seen that happen before right it's
not uncommon to see that i mean it's
kind of uncommon we've only seen it once
but it's not unheard of so that's one of
the cool things these aren't really just
being yanked out of nowhere we've seen
this kind of stuff happen before and so
what they end up doing is basically
tracing this kind of main source of
energy the brain so to speak of how all
this stuff works down to this kind of
weird pit of sorts only for nor rad for
the silver surfer to emerge and then
basically say like come and see right
like come and join us and this is
something that we haven't really seen
from the marvel zombies right is with
the marvel zombies it was we have to
spread the gospel that's what the marvel
zombies always said we never really saw
them say come and see or we never really
heard them say come and see and so this
is cool this is interesting it's a
wholly new take it looks like on the
entire marvel zombies mythos but the
overall gist of this is this is when the
dying starts and the first one to fall
is johnny storm after that all hell
begins to break loose magic is consumed
by the zombies who in turn along with a
whole bunch of other people end up
attacking magneto and so magneto falls
the cool thing about this is that
captain america is only a matter of time
before he falls right and he actually
directs thor to get out to get out of
there as fast as he can to basically go
back to james rhodes who's been stowing
away or been sitting on the ship in case
things pop off and then fly it back to
earth now thor of course being the
warrior that we know he is is not
readily willing to just leave his
friends behind right like you got a cap
and then just bail
that's not really what thor does thor
wants to fight into the bitter end we
would expect nothing less of his
character but at the end of the day he's
directed by captain america and this is
the kind of respect that captain america
commands within the superhero universe
right but it's like get out of here go
back to earth if you fall the whole
world will fall and so as a result of
that thor ends up coming face to face
with gladiator and this is a fight that
i don't think we've ever really seen
right like uh like in the modern era a
bare knuckle brawl between thor and
gladiator the downside of this is that
we don't see it we never get to see that
take place instead johnny storm
basically falls susan storm ends up
trying to rescue him as best she can it
doesn't work ah ben grimm ends up taking
out johnny storm and then everything
continues to kind of run amuck
everything begins to panic only for for
susan storm to in turn become a zombie
herself try to stop reed richards and
then it seems as though reed richards
basically gets turned right like reed
richards ends up becoming a zombie
himself and so as a result of that when
james rose is sitting on the ship and
he's like okay so what's going on thor
comes flying out he believes it's help
only for us to find out it's a zombified
thor and then in turn like they just go
they go heading back to earth inside
galactus right like in the span of
minutes and that's the thing to
understand here this wasn't a battle
that took place over the course of a day
in a matter of minutes all the
superheroes that were there all of them
fall just like that and it's kind of a
sight to behold it's kind of amazing to
see that right because ultimately what
ends up happening is is where you end up
having uh peter parker basically talking
to valeria richards and so on and uh
supposedly franklin richards is around
there somewhere uh galactus basically
comes crashing down to earth and this is
kind of the cool thing here because
here's my question here's my real big
question here when all of the marvel
zombies show up on the on earth in the
main marvel universe can franklin
richards stop them and if franklin
richards cannot stop them what happens
if franklin richards becomes one of them
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking up with uh marvel zombies
resurrection the one shot like the story
that kind of said hey like marvel
zombies is coming back it came out like
a year ago right so if i'm being honest
i think marvel may have kind of missed
the hype i think marvel got wind of the
fact that dc was doing a zombie story
and marvel wanted to beat him to the
punch but then didn't really have a plan
so nothing ever came out after and then
we got deceased in the mid time which is
like an amazing story so i don't know
like i'm not really sure what the grand
plan is with this i mean it's only four
issues right so it's not super lengthy
uh but nonetheless in the the
resurrection one shot right it was the
idea that like galactus was kind of out
there in space just kind of seemed to be
floating or what have you but the
various superheroes were at least a
series of superheroes went out there to
investigate what was going on and some
pretty heavy hitters ended up traveling
out there for the purpose of like
understanding what was happening right
because they may need uh some pretty
heavy hitters especially when you're
dealing with galactus or something like
that we ended up basically finding out
that like the zombie infection was there
right and i don't believe that we got an
origin point we'll just say where it
came from i believe it was just there
but regardless uh all these various
superheroes ended up coming back to
earth who were infected and of course
the whole zombie apocalypse spread fast
now we're not given a whole lot in terms
of like how it was that it's spread
which kind of makes sense in the
original zombie story we never got that
the original zombie story just seemingly
picked up in the middle of everything
and then just kind of went forward from
there right but uh but nonetheless you
know we may end up getting some kind of
backstory either later on in this series
or possibly it's like a companion series
like a tie-in that marvel might release
somewhere along the line but the overall
gist is that because peter parker had at
one point in time been part of the uh of
the the future foundation which was kind
of an offshoot of the fantastic four and
even part of the fantastic four team
itself ultimately he was tasked by reed
and susan to keep an eye on valeria and
and franklin right to basically keep an
eye on them to make sure they stay safe
and it's kind of interesting that
franklin's here because he has such vast
reality warping powers i'm kind of
curious what role he's going to play
right because where peter is basically
rescuing them and trying to get them out
of harm's way give them as far away from
the conflict as they possibly can of
course the vulture swoops in the vulture
you know takes out a part of the part of
the the thing um and it's like okay you
know like not a great big huge deal but
then here comes johnny storm and johnny
storm because of the fact that he's
infected comes crashing into the device
and basically sends like the entire ship
crashing down right so it has like
valeria and everybody just like fleeing
for their life like you know crying
carrying on then peter parker kind of
falls now that's where we sort of pick
up with what's going on in the moment
right that was kind of the outbreak
moment right that's that's all we really
got and then at the moment right now we
basically have uh we've got moonstone
here i don't know why moonstone is here
uh but then you've also got franklin
you've got you got franklin a little bit
older you got valeria and you've got
forge now for moonstone an important
thing to understand about her character
is it seems like she may or may not play
a more significant role later she had
the ability to like manipulate light she
had super strength super speed different
things like that she's by no means a
show stopper but she is here because
she's one of the survivors and what
seems to have been going on here is that
led by forge uh they're just traveling
from one location to the next seemingly
trying to use fortress uh forge's track
to basically locate like a safe haven
but they've just kind of been on this
journey not too long after the the fall
of what seems to be new york and
probably the rest of the world to find
some measure of a safe haven the issue
with this is that along the way of
course we're kind of given this idea
that making noise different things like
that is not a good idea because it'll
attract what they call the uh the
respawn which is basically just you know
the undead and the result of this is is
this kind of like okay like they end up
you know killing a few of them and
that's basically it but the really big
moment that kind of comes out of all
this is that once those forces are
destroyed you end up having the
appearance of nightcrawler and this is
one of the coolest things right because
nightcrawler is a character that's
painfully underrated in marvel comics
right in in a lot of different ways and
i say that because i think that that as
x-men fans we know the worth of of
nightcrawler but it's one of these
things like when you see him unless you
were reading like the manifest destiny
nightcrawler story there weren't a whole
lot of instances where he was given like
any real do and so of course with him
teleporting around the other part of
this is that forge is basically familiar
with with nightcrawler familiar enough
that he's able to take this guy on and
ultimately take him out but the other
thing that goes on here is he's
basically using the optic visor of
cyclops now the visor is attached to a
rig on his back right so like obviously
he's channeling energy from there i
don't really know why the cycle the the
optic beams of cyclops are necessary
unless you know ford somehow found some
kind of device where he's using a kind
of energy where you know using the the
beams of cyclops or at least the visor
of cyclops seems to be the most useful
with nightcrawler teleporting around
they simply can't keep up with them and
so what we end up doing is getting the
appearance of nana now nana is a
character they had kind of been talking
about that valeria had been mentioning a
couple times and that she you know that
franklin takes very close to nana uh and
and it really kind of views nana as like
a surrogate you know mother figure
almost or somebody there to take care of
him but nana was basically reprogrammed
by uh by valeria and the reason why is
because nana is just a great big huge
sentinel right it's just like literally
it looks like an omega sentinel like an
office a national emergency sentinel uh
but it was reprogrammed by valeria for
the purpose of protecting franklin now
one thing to understand this is kind of
a funny thing when it comes to marvel
size isn't everything just because
you're big doesn't necessarily mean
you're you're really worth anything what
it really comes down to this is going in
all the wrong ways
what it really comes down to is the foe
you're facing off against and for all
the size the sentinels have they're
actually pretty easy to take out like
believe it or not like they're pretty
easy to destroy just a being of
sufficient power now we don't really
know what modifications have been made
to nana and that's really where things
kind of stand the test of what's going
on we don't really know what
modifications have been made and valeria
is probably the smartest person in the
world right now assuming that doctor
doom's not alive we know that reed
basically was taken by the by the
zombies so like at least he was one of
the early ones to be infected uh and so
because that it's like okay i wonder
what is what is fully capable of right
because it's one thing one is when it's
machines rebuilding themselves but
machines are still limited by what they
understand at that point in time and
valeria is much smarter than a machine
right she's the smartest person in the
world and even before reid and assuming
doom died she was still one of the
smartest people in the world she was she
kind of switched the number one spot
with those three guys and so for her to
rebuild this in such a way it seems
pretty interesting but the other part of
this is that peter takes personal
offense to the idea of forge actually
leading them to the x-men mansion
because what he feels like is they've
kind of been manipulated now this is
sort of the issue you run into with this
right this is one of the issues that you
run into with how zombies resurrection
is being done so far because we get so
little backstory because we get so
little brick and mortar kind of filling
things in the reason and the motivations
for why characters feel the way they do
is kind of lost on us we know peter
parker was tasked with keeping valeria
and franklin safe we know that nan is
also there and that peter parker will
always keep an eye on them we don't know
how they ran into moonstone we don't
really know why it is that he's pissed
off about the fact that that forge
brought them to the xavier mansion
outside of the fact that like you know
you've just been accidentally leading us
here to the xavier institute you know i
mean there is a kind of explanation
insofar as like because of the fact that
the xavier institute housed so many
mutants that if we show up here and
these mutants are infected like we're
guaranteed to die but at the end of the
day peter has a spider sense now the
other thing going on is because of
spider-sense is happening all the time
he's developing like these headaches and
forge's theory is that if they go on
long enough they'll basically kill him
right so like they've got to finally
basically find a place to one keep peter
safe so his spider sins can calm down
and two like basically a refuge of sorts
right forge's stands for being here
makes a lot more sense and in the in the
idea that the xavier institute was a
veritable fortress right there's food
and resources to last them 500 years
there's all kinds of technology there
more so than that he believes that they
can find some kind of a ship to get them
to the to the space arcs and that's one
of the first indications that we get
that humanity fled the planet right then
in light of everything that was going on
humanity bailed because of that once
they finally make their way into the
house and they they basically start
poking around uh they find a few things
right the place looks kind of like it
was kind of ransacked to a degree
there's the concern that any of the
resources that were there could be taken
but then they find all this crazy
writing on the wall and this writing
belongs to a group called the deadheads
right and the idea was that when the
outbreak happened that there kind of
arose a sort of cult that saw the
deadheads or saw like the the respawns
right like you know beings who who were
basically reanimated as being like the
next step in evolution it is kind of
crazy but one of the important things
this does tell us is that no small
measure of time had passed between when
the outbreak originally happened and
when everything got to this point right
so while i wouldn't necessarily go as
far as to say it's been something like
five or ten years i would go as far as
to say it's probably been a few years
valeria certainly looks older franklin
looks a little bit older right so we'll
say maybe something like four years or
so again we're not given an exact time
frame here it's just you know and now
we're in this moment and things are
popping off but once they end up
approaching what looks like the pantry
they basically end up hearing a kind of
noise right they basically say like
we've got weapons you know like we'll
kill you if you try to attack us they
open the door and it's a bunch it looks
like a bunch of humans in there right
like a bunch of regular people and this
is really one of the things where peter
parker is interesting because of course
they end up basically you know
liberating them and setting them free
and when peter kind of starts to cry a
little bit forge's idea is that it's
like the old days right when they used
to save innocent people that kind of a
thing and peter's response is no that's
not why i'm crying i'm crying because
what awaits them out there is worse than
whatever it was that was coming for them
whatever it was that was here and my
first thought was to just do them in
right so like spare them trying to make
it out there they won't last today right
like they'll end up being turned or
worse and like my thought was i should
just take them out and just make it
easier right peter parker was thinking
about just killing those people because
it would have been an easier easier
thing for them to deal with than
everything else out there and that's
wildly different for peter parker right
like that's that's wildly out of
character for peter it's not something
that he would do and that's designed to
really show us how bad things have
gotten like how far how far things have
fallen again marvel kind of just running
through things really fast and i feel
like if i'm being honest with you guys i
feel like it really needs a little more
umph you know a little more meat and
potatoes to it you know you know to kind
of flush things out of it i really feel
like that's what this needs but of
course this leads to the return of the
deadheads and one of the things that
that kind of goes on is they they
basically say that like those folks were
tributes but they were tributes that
were being fed to basically the all
strong this individual there who was
consuming those individuals and with the
dead heads themselves they were
considered to be kind of not really i
guess they were assets to a degree but
so long as they were doing what they
were doing they would be spared right
they'd be allowed to kind of continue
existing and so it's it's one part
obsession and an almost cult-like
mentality and the other part just
self-preservation it's kind of what that
seemed to be but basically their whole
thing is like the all-strong is going to
come here now like when he gets here
like there's no hope for any of you guys
you have no idea what it is that you've
done and ultimately you kind of started
hearing this sort of you know booming
sound and this kind of rumbling you know
and so on and and basically like this
guy kind of starts to pray to the all
strong and the all strong ends up of
course biting him in half only for us to
find out this is beast right that hank
mccoy being infected while he was there
or else being infected and going there
has taken up residence in the xavier
institute now initially there is an
attempt to rationalize with him right
like forge tries to rationalize with
beast and say look like we can find a
cure right like we need you like we need
you hank mccoy like we know you're still
in there somewhere we need your mind we
need your intelligence you know you're
one of the foremost geneticists right
you understand the nature of human
biology if anybody can fix this it would
be you and beast basically kind of
utters the word cure and then says like
it's you were curing and then kills
forge and so this really seems to take a
page out of the original zombies where
they're still very much cognizant they
know exactly who they are they're not
really mindless beasts right so it's
different from deceased in that sense
and the way that like the dc's
characters who are out there are just
like attacking things right like they
almost kind of seem to be completely
mindless unless you're being led by
somebody like you know uh like like adam
or something like that somebody who
somehow managed to maintain a higher
level of thinking but that on the whole
they're not really kind of what they
used to be right i mean in this one
they're still pretty intelligent now
with forge being killed this leads to
nana intervening and nana basically goes
to attack beast and then of course beast
ends up attacking nana and of course
this leads into the arrival of chewie
now chewie had was was there and it
consumed some of the zombies they had to
dealt with along you know that they had
to deal with leading up to basically the
the showing up of nightcrawler uh but
chewie was a character who appeared in
giant-sized captain marvel i think it
was giant-sized cat maybe it was
giant-sized miss marvel number one
during house of m chewie is what's
called a flurk and basically you see
chewy in like the marvel cinematic
universe when it's the cat that can eat
anything but one thing to understand is
the misconception there chewie doesn't
really like i mean it can consume almost
anything but it doesn't really just let
out tentacles the idea is that flirkins
contain with inside their own bodies
basically like pocket dimensions like an
infinite amount of space inside of a
finite space as crazy as that sounds but
within that space they can house any
number of things for chewy it's housing
a mouth that can consume pretty much
anything and that's basically what
happens here like chewy ends up
manifesting and then subduing beasts
like grabbing beasts bringing it in
killing him basically like like doing
beast in and that's it right like peter
parker kind of jumps in and and you know
basically you end up having beasts whose
head is completely severed from his body
and then from there it's like okay right
like moonstone more or less save the day
to a degree alongside nana and then they
start asking beasts like what in the
world is going on here right like like
franklin approaches beast and says like
where are my parents where are my mom
and dad because these these zombies
aren't necessarily individual thinkers
right they share a singular hive mind
right like they they see what all the
others see and that's one of the things
that they warn is like because beast has
seen us now it means that like wherever
we are like everybody else knows where
we are and if they knew that beast was
in the xavier institute then now they
all know we're in the xavier institute
now this is incredibly important and the
reason why is because if these zombies
are functioning with a higher level of
intelligence then this is strategy put
each one of them in a particular
location to where heroes will most
likely take refuge at and when they
arrive suddenly everybody else knows
they're there and if they're looking for
somebody in particular if they're
looking for franklin or they're looking
for valeria then they will know where
they are at and that's exactly what's
revealed here they're hunting for
franklin richards one thing to
understand is that franklin's powers
don't seem to be working for some reason
we don't really know exactly why but
he's not really able to use his reality
working powers it was kind of an
offhanded remark that was made earlier
by valeria but the implication seems to
be he doesn't really have his high
levels of telepathy telekinesis matter
manipulation or anything like that if he
did he could certainly use those and
save the day but also remember there's a
big difference between franklin as a
little kid and franklin as a full-on
adult when adult franklin richard showed
up during hickman's avengers and new
avengers he had i'm sorry during his a
fantastic four run he had total control
of his power right he knew how to do
anything he wanted to do and he just
required the power of his younger self
in order to take on the other celestials
so that it was basically like two
franklins and one but he still knew how
to use his powers one of the big
problems that franklin's always had as a
little kid is he never really knew how
to use his abilities he was never really
trained on how to use his powers by read
there was always something else going on
or there were mental blocks put in place
whatever the case was and so because of
that it made things a little complicated
for franklin's character but what beast
basically says here is like your family
is with the galactus hive now no one's
seen the galactus hive for quite some
time and so either they've taken it
somewhere it's hidden but nobody knows
where it's at and then basically b says
like they're hunting for you franklin
like we are looking for you and we are
going to find you like come and see your
mother and father right like come back
to manhattan and we'll find out what's
going on and so at that point you end up
having you know moonstone who basically
destroys the head of beast and then she
takes off now the reason she takes off
is because of the fact that in her mind
going on a suicide mission to the
galactus hive is kind of stupid right
like the whole reason she joined peter
parker in the first place is that she
was attracted to the kind of fatherly
role that peter was playing for franklin
and valerie right she liked that but
more so than that they seem to have a
purpose right and one of the things she
talks about is like in the early days of
the invasion of new york you had bucky
barnes you had a few people here and
there who were fighting off against the
invasion right so again a good amount of
time seems to have passed here but they
had a role to play right it was good
guys versus bad guys things were pretty
straightforward but peter parker isn't
really much of a hero anymore he's lost
in in almost every conceivable way the
way that uh the way that moonstone sees
it and then in turn going on a suicide
mission to the galactus hive seems even
worse and so she's like you guys go do
your thing but i am not going with you
right like i'm not going on some suicide
mission to the galactus hive in an
effort to find the parents the the you
know zombie appearance of some kid so he
can have some hope that's not going to
work but the other perspective from like
valeria and franklin is far less grim
right in their mind valeria even asked
the question what makes us think they're
not some kind of evolutionary next step
right like what keeps us from thinking
that what keeps it from being true it is
entirely possible and reid always said
like there would be a way like there's
always a way we're talking about a
biological organism there has to be a
cure for this and so it's really hope
against hope with valeria and franklin
believing they can find reed and they
can actually bring things back to normal
now the way in which they're able to
find the galactus hive comes from
valeria and it's actually pretty genius
because of the fact that beast was on
the original mission that essentially
discovered this radiation where they
were infected and they began to end up
becoming zombies that because that
radiation is still prevalent and beast
they can actually track its source and
they can get back to the galactus hive
now peter jumps in the way and says this
is ridiculous right like you cannot cure
a dead organism it doesn't work this way
it's not how that kind of stuff works
and it's kind of the hope of franklin
and valeria how do you know they're dead
how do you know that they are actually
dead like there's no real way to know
there i mean maybe they are maybe
they're not but like we can go there we
can we can tend to them and we can find
out and so of course when you end up
having them more or less kind of camping
for a bit peter parker getting some rest
and then waking up only to find that
like valeria and franklin and them are
gone he goes on the hunt for them only
to be attacked out of nowhere and for us
to find out that moonstone has become
infected and where she goes to attack
peter parker suddenly she starts getting
chopped into pieces peter also finds
franklin valeria right so they're still
safe but like she starts getting chopped
into little pieces and when that happens
then suddenly we get this kind of
question coming out of nowhere right
like let me see and then we find out
that it's blade before this one showed
up i overheard you know the other two
saying you guys are gonna go find the
galactus hive do you have room for one
more right so now they're here with
blade and believe it or not that makes a
difference right blade being here the
day is in a lot of ways saved
but what we end up doing here is we kind
of pick up before the events of the main
story taking place right we basically
get a bit of a flashback here and the
idea is that when the initial outbreak
first happened peter parker is
spider-man and so on and so forth he's
immediately attacked by basically the
fantastic four reed richards ben grimm
johnny storm and susan storm and they
end up kind of grabbing franklin and
valeria and the whole reason behind this
is that where they arrive here of course
it's their kids and they kind of say
that like in our previous life they were
our family but we have a new family now
and these kids are going to join us in
this new family and so you basically end
up having peter of course begging for
them you know begging for the fantastic
four to leave the kids alone but
ultimately susan storm ends up biting
franklin richards and so what this
points to is the idea that franklin is
infected right that's basically what it
looks like it's it's kind of nuts here
one of the other big questions that sort
of has to be asked is why franklin
richard's hair is dark at this point in
time and now it's blonde we can kind of
assume that it was basically dyed and
he's gone back to his natural hair color
you know over this this time period but
you end up basically having this this
scenario where you kind of wake up with
peter in the present moment and they're
basically heading towards the phalanx
wall now the explanation of this is
essentially given to us by blade and
let's be honest with ourselves the only
reason blade's in this story is because
of the fact that he's getting a movie
if it wasn't for that we probably
wouldn't see him in here which may be
one of the reasons why it took so long
for the story to come out is that once
blade was announced for the mcu marvel
basically had to go back and just
rewrite the whole story to put blade in
it but the idea is that blade basically
says that initially what humanity did is
they created machines right robots you
know artificial intelligence organisms
they were kind of created by a coalition
between shield and advanced idea
mechanics to fight the dead when they
first showed up here because machines
cannot be consumed by the virus but what
ended up happening is that despite their
best efforts the various you know marvel
zombies ended up pushing humanity to the
brink of almost near extinction and so
because there aren't really any more
humans running the show here the
machines have kind of become their own
self-governing entity their own
self-governing society and they
basically fight against the zombies to
control the world it's really what what
you know kind of a subplot that seems to
be going on here and so when the
question is asked why blades even part
of this in the first place he's like
because i just kill the undead right i
don't really care about you or franklin
or valeria or anything like that you
guys are a means to an end right you
guys can help me get from one location
to the next but understand if you die
it's not the biggest thing to me but
while they're traveling they're suddenly
set upon by marvel zombies right like
the eradicator from alpha flight and i'd
like to point out here this is probably
the most useful alpha flight's ever been
in the history of their publications
when they're zombies and they attack
like peter parker and everybody else and
they do what alpha flight does which is
die uh so these guys are basically
destroyed
because alpha flight sucks and uh and
this this basically leads to them of
course kind of crashing down so on and
so forth and immediately set upon by
like a whole host of zombies but in the
middle of all this they're met by the
arrival of a nimrod right like a nimrod
sentinel now here's the funny thing
about this and something that i'm not
overly fond of here this nimrod sentinel
is basically just an agent of the
machine coalition right the machine
group right these these robots that are
kind of out here nimrod here's a here's
an important thing to understand with
why i view this right long before
hickman started writing x-men nimrod has
historically been kind of like the
one-two punch of the sentinel program
there he came from days of future past
right in days of future past the machine
or the sentinel program was jump started
after the assassination of senators
robert or senator robert kelly and
charles xavier of the x-men and more
mctaggart but the sentinels ended up
coming to the realization that if
humanity tasked them with tracking down
and eliminating mutants that much like
what you saw in x-men the animated
series that mutants are the next level
of human evolution and at their base
level mutants are human and so in turn
they turned on the entirety of humanity
but in their in the in the process of
doing that the sentinels were constantly
trying to find a way to better
themselves and the the you know this
this basically kind of coalesced in the
creation of the nimrod sentinel that had
the ability to like analyze a mutant
understand their powers and basically
find uh find ways to counter those
powers and so it was really just like a
super powerful being right here he's
just a guy that's there and is attacking
the various marvel zombies now but you
basically end up having nana the
sentinel who kind of attacks the marvel
zombies and it's really just kind of you
know these robots sort of locking
everybody down right like the other part
of the other thing that kind of comes
out of this is you've got viv the
daughter of vision who's kind of running
you know seems to be the one running
this show you've got a doombot but
you've also got frank castle who's
basically a robot as well and we get
this sort of explanation you know once
they're all taken and they start talking
to viv that one viv isn't really who she
used to be right she's not as kind of
outgoing and and great as she used to be
instead you know her components have
kind of been replaced over the years and
so while she hasn't totally lost herself
she's really more enveloped in the realm
of being a machine than she is being
more human right so she's kind of to a
degree lost that human element vivian is
socially awkward
it's essentially what's kind of going on
here the other part of this is that the
last time valeria saw vivian it was
actually her and miles morales who were
traveling to an outbreak zone right in
hell's kitchen but miles morales didn't
survive and that was kind of what led to
vivian sort of losing her humanity was
looking around and realizing how many
people she cared about were being killed
off and that there's strength in being a
robot that can't really be converted the
other thing that i got on here is that
with frank castle the reason why he
looks the way he does is that being
human being organic makes you
susceptible to the virus and so he had
willingly undergone exposure to the
transmode virus which basically has
converted him into a cybernetic organism
and so essentially he's really more
machine than man twisted and evil an
agent to the dark side now
but that's basically what he is he's
basically kind of a walking talking
cyborg you know and he chose that path
and so what they're all kind of taken to
what they believe to be is going to be
you know more or less a safe haven they
end up finding out they're being taken
to a location where the transmog virus
is going to run its course and they're
going to be converted into a machine now
initially there's there's an attempt by
valeria to appeal to vivian but vivian
doesn't really hear it she's like you
know we're going to make you stronger
right we're going to make you better
we're going to basically get rid of any
toxicity you have in your system and
then we're going to then we're going to
fix you right we're going to turn you
into what basically what frank castle is
the other thing and it's really kind of
an easy thing to notice here the other
thing is they talk about franklin right
they say what about the boy he's unaware
of his nature right but he would be a
great value against the respawn and this
is kind of important here because it
looks like franklin's powers are more or
less gone but what this seems to point
out is that his powers are not gone that
his powers are very much intact and this
would easily explain why it is that
while being attacked here that he's not
somebody who turned right he didn't turn
into one of the zombies that he's still
very much alive and so from there you
kind of have this discussion about the
nature of the of these these respawn
like these marvel zombies and what we
kind of get here is this full-on
explanation of what they are the funny
thing is that in the main marvel zombies
story that was written by robert kirkman
back in the day that until you got to
the the tie-in involving the evil dead
there wasn't really any explanation of
how the marvel zombies worked outside of
their zombies and that's basically it
right it was a dark humor story and you
just kind of went on existing knowledge
about zombies and went forward from
there right it wasn't really a comic
that was meant to be taken super
seriously with this one it looks like
marvel's kind of following the standard
fare of like offering an explanation and
basically saying that it's not really
them being undead in a traditional sense
that what it is is it's a kind of
sub-microbial parasitic organism that
shares a collective consciousness and
that when a person is bitten or infected
they're infected with this microbial
organism and that basically kills the
body and then in turn kind of takes it
over and brings it into part of the hive
mind and so she basically says like
there is no cure here and it doesn't
necessarily seem to be true right if the
microbial organism kills the body then i
guess yes there is no cure in so far as
those individuals who have been infected
can actually be saved uh instead you'd
have to kill the microbial organism
which in turn means the body would just
shut back down again right so that would
basically be it uh and so it's like
killing the brain and just nothing else
can follow right the body just can't
function after that so so there is no
cure in so far as like hey we can save
everybody out there and make them back
the way they were but there is a cure in
the sense that you can kill the organism
and basically wipe out all the zombies
the problem with this is that there's
this massive explosion there are massive
you know booming that kind of takes
place outside the building and it's kind
of like you know like what is that right
like that felt close you know can
something actually bring this down and
the the response of vivian is like
nothing out there can bring this down
short of any attack from like a hulk and
that's exactly what it is it's not just
a hulk it's the hulk family man it's the
incredible hulk it's she-hulk it is uh
scar the son of the hulk and it's the
red hulk on top of that it's been grim
the thing it's gladiator and hyperion
like it's the big heavy hitters of like
the marvel universe coming down here to
just rain down hell fire death and
destruction right it's judgment day in
this facility
because literally they just started
ripping all the robots to pieces right
just like tearing all these guys apart
and so at that point vivian's just like
run that's all we can do here is just
run that's the best we can do it's just
flea for our lives right like just get
out of here as fast as we can the other
part of this is at the nana sentinel
vivian basically says that they were
essentially running a program running a
subroutine that would kind of cleanse
her programming as it was done by peter
parker and then kind of turn her back
into the way she is or the way she's
supposed to be as far as like an agent
of the of the machine group the problem
is that the program hasn't really had a
chance to run its course and so she's
kind of stuck in that space in between
and so you end up basically having nana
showing up and kind of saving the day to
a degree and basically grabbing
everybody jumping on board and then her
flying off the problem with this is that
the incredible hulk jumps after them and
as you guys know the incredible hulk can
jump fast and far because of his leg
strength right because of just the over
overwhelming amount of strength he has
and vivian asked the question of peter
parker why are you really going after
galactus right like what's the point of
this and peter initially responds and
saying like i told you it's because of
the kids and she says no why are you
going right like why are you doing this
why are you bringing the kids there and
peter says because he wants to believe
in something again peter feels hopeless
he feels hopeless on all of this he
feels hopeless because you know he's the
reason franklin got infected he feels
hopeless because the entire superhuman
superhero community fell and there was
nothing he could really do but i would
say there's a bigger guilt going on here
than that i would say that there came a
point in this battle when peter realized
he couldn't win and fled fear got the
better of him and he ran away and left
people to die right i would say that's
probably what really happened here but
with vivian getting that response from
peter she basically says fine then like
do whatever you need to do find
something to believe in and she
sacrifices herself to the incredible
hulk right she goes to attack him and
basically knock him to the ground vivian
as we know is probably going to die and
so what you end up getting here is it
looks like this moment when peter kind
of seems to entertain this idea of
reactivating franklin's powers right of
like turning franklin's powers back on
we're not really given a definitive
explanation if that's the case but you
end up having you know valeria who's
kind of using this this radiation
detector to locate galactus signal and
starts to realize like we're getting
closer as they're flying and what it
seems like is they're out in the middle
of nowhere right they're literally out
in the middle of the ocean and when the
question is asked by peter like it
doesn't really make any sense like we're
out here in the middle of nowhere the
galactus hive always went for population
centers why would we be here the
response to valeria is can you not think
of a population center in the atlantic
ocean and she's like we're headed for
the atlantis colony we're headed for
what would be the kingdom of neymar the
submariner
oh
rob core i have been up since 5 30 this
morning it didn't matter what time it is
i'm exhausted
i am so tired uh what's up guys we are
here with part four of of marvel zombies
resurrection and in the the previous
video that we had we kind of ended that
with the heroes heading towards atlantis
and the funny thing about this we get a
bit of an explanation here but we get
this explanation after we kind of jump
back to the past and i sort of like the
way this is being done and so far it's
kind of giving us these little
flashbacks here and there kind of
building up a bit of the mystery and
when the initial outbreak happened and
galactus basically arrived on earth we
ended up of course seeing the fantastic
four who were there who were some of the
early infected and along with you know a
whole bunch of the other uh superheroes
and whatnot but susan had basically
taken franklin right and the idea was
that they were going to take franklin
and valeria and they were going to
essentially infect them and bring them
into quote unquote the family right the
family is kind of a general term that
the infected use for for the kind of
hive mind that they basically share and
so the result is that franklin is
basically infected with the with this
virus whatever the wherever the heck
this happens to be and so it's kind of
nuts because one of the things that that
susan tells uh tells peter is that mary
jane's infected as well and she'll be
coming for him too and so peter parker
ends up kind of basically rushing in he
incapacitates johnny storm a little bit
and then grabs franklin valeria and then
basically takes off and so following
that where he's basically trying to get
away we jump back to what's going on
right now right we jump back to this
this moment here so again i'm really
kind of curious to see how the story of
peter and franklin and valeria really
led to the modern day but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comedy
i'm not gonna do that to you guys
i'm not gonna do that to you guys but
making their way towards uh the atlantic
we actually find out a few things that
are going on here and that's why i say
this kind of passage of time is a little
murky right like it's a little murky
here in the sense that we kind of have
to assume like in this this moment when
galactus and company crash landed on
earth we kind of have to assume that the
superheroes being infected spread pretty
rapidly right because superheroes are
capable of incredible speed and
different things like that and so it
kind of makes sense that it would have
been the heroes right the heroes would
have would have spread the spread this
virus whatever it is around the world
pretty fast now my only real frame of
reference for that comes from either
seeing traditional zombie movies right
so you know like you you see just how
fast plagues spread um with like you
know the what was the dawn of the dead
the remake from 2006 which was amazing
from like 14 years ago there's different
zombie comics that we have uh but what
we kind of what we're kind of told here
is that around the time that this
infection kicked off that there was a
shield advanced idea mechanics coalition
that basically rehabilitated atlantis as
a colony for people who could breathe
air and so it seems like a good amount
of time has passed right because one
just to get shield and advanced idea
mechanics to work together okay in the
midst of a crisis that can happen over
the course of a day but even with their
resources it takes more than a week to
do something like that right to like
retrofit atlantis to make it habitable
for people who can breathe air and then
allow people down there right because at
that point we'd largely have to assume
that atlantis was still populated that
atlantis was okay with it atlantis never
really cared about the surface world so
there's some politicking that would go
on in that situation but regardless we
can largely probably assume about a week
passed between the time like the initial
initial outbreak happened and this
moment and i'm being pretty liberal with
that time frame if i want to be a little
more conservative i'd say maybe two or
three days right well whatever the case
is we basically had this you know as you
know atlantis kind of functioning as a
refuge or at least it was supposed to be
and the issue is they're they're on the
trail of galactus right they're going
after the galactus hive and the trail of
galactus takes them to atlantis and so
it looks like it all kind of leads here
right this is kind of like the home base
of the infected now as soon as they show
up they're immediately met by a kind of
rumble right this giant monster comes
out of the water and then they're met
with namor the submariner and a whole
host of atlanteans now at this point all
you can do is run right like that's
really all you can do i mean one namor
is enough to take almost any of them out
except for like spider-man possibly
blade but two like name with a
submariner and that many zombies there's
only so much you can do and so the
result of this is that you end up having
peter parker getting a hold of nana
who's the sentinel and basically saying
get us down the elevator shaft right
like get us down that shaft close the
door behind us let's get out of here as
fast as we can and so what you end up
getting is is them kind of descending
down making their way to the bottom of
this place but as soon as they get down
there or at least as they're making
their way down there the initial thought
here of peter is we need to just leave
the atlanteans are already attacking us
and if atlantis was supposed to be
rehabilitated there's a really good
chance that the entire atlantis colony
fell we're literally descending into a
giant like a giant hive of zombies right
like why would we want to do that but
the stance that valeria really offers
here is that they have to find the
galactus hive because it's the host more
so than that the way that beast had kind
of talked about these things a little
bit that she kind of picks up on here is
that it's possible for her to possibly
reprogram this virus so to speak to
basically remove the hunger but keep
them the way they are and so essentially
they have no need to feed the funny
thing about this is that from what we're
seeing or at least what we saw with a
flashback to susan storm it's less about
feeding and it's more about growing the
hive it's not really a traditional
zombie concept where it's we need to eat
brains because that's what we do it's a
legitimate desire to spread as many
infected or spread the infection as much
as they can so whether or not they have
to consume anything doesn't really
matter it doesn't really play into it
and so valeria is either operating on
half information or it's just one of
those aspects of the plot that doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense and
it's just kind of like you know because
you have to assume even if she wasn't
conscious when everything happened with
susan and all them then she had to
figure that out along the way right
somebody must have said something or
their mannerisms or statements or what
have you but like we just want to expand
the hive like that kind of a thing you
know and so the results of this is that
once they get to the bottom there's all
these all this writing right like the
eighth pillar black spring all this
stuff like all this kind of writing and
spray paint and whatnot that's all out
there you know come and see and and so
on but the place looks like it
completely and totally went to pot right
it completely totally went to pieces but
the crazy thing about this is we don't
know if it was some kind of religious
zealotry we don't know if it was really
like zombie infected we don't know if
people just went insane the other part
of this is the nature of black spring
that beast had talked about and he
talked about the world behind worlds but
there wasn't a whole lot of information
given right so it's just a concept that
they're aware of but they don't really
have any information behind it the issue
with this is that as they kind of
continue and make their way in there
comes a point where flanking kind of
disappears franklin vanishes for a
second peter of course catches up and
and it's really kind of franklin being
sad here right kind of being a little
bit more rose and the reason why is and
this is kind of the intuitive nature of
franklin that sure he's not book smart
in the same way valeria is but he can
pick up on more than a few things and
the stance that he has here is that
valeria believes that they can save
susan and reed and ben and and johnny
and everybody else right they believe
they can save everybody or at least she
does but the stance of franklin is we
can't right if there was a cure that
could have been found somebody probably
would have found it by now because there
have to be other research stations going
on just by sheer common sense they can't
be the only people out there who are not
infected and capable of doing research
or looking into things but the other
part of that is that it kind of shifts
the the tables a little bit right
because historically franklin was always
somewhat of the wide-eyed and the one
who kind of saw the best in things right
like the hopeful one he was always that
kind of guy valeria was really more of
the by the books look at things at how
you know look at things as they are
really more of the left-brained kind of
person right and franklin was more the
right brain if that makes any sense to
you guys and so the results of this is
is kind of a shift right franklin is
kind of in this moment where it's like i
really don't think we can save anybody
maybe we can but then he asked peter
he's like what happened like the night
that i was infected right why is it that
i don't age what happened to my powers
like how did i lose my powers like
what's going on here now it's kind of
nuts the idea that that peter
potentially did something to shut down
franklin's powers which in turn stops
his aging it's kind of crazy but if i'm
being honest with you guys if i'm if i'm
a betting man here and this is a theory
that is probably totally kooky probably
100 wrong but i wouldn't be surprised if
somewhere along the line in the
aftermath of this that franklin or or
either peter had somehow stopped
franklin's uh you know kind of tapped
into his powers to kind of shut them
down which in turn would keep it from
aging and keep the infection from
spreading or it might be kind of like a
house of m-type thing valeria had kind
of gone to franklin or somebody gone to
finland put the idea in his head of like
freeze everything right like freeze
reality i mean people kind of move
forward and the sun rises and sun sets
but like nobody ages nobody progresses
you don't have to worry about the virus
kind of spreading within you anymore or
something like that i don't know it's
kind of an off-the-cuff idea and it's
it's it's a pretty shoddy theory at best
to be honest with you guys but i think
it might be kind of cool if marvel had
it worked out but they end up realizing
there's a person that's kind of chained
up kind of held up way on the back side
right like way on on the other side of
the this kind of big open vestibule and
when they get there they realize that
it's logan right like it's wolverine and
because of the healing factor that he
has for a period of time his body was
constantly healing itself and they were
literally just feeding on him they were
just kind of using him as a food
resource but the issue is that
wolverine's healing factor seemingly has
burned out meaning that he can only heal
so far and this is evident by the fact
that he's lost his eyes and his eyes
didn't heal back right he doesn't
realize that it's peter parker peter
parker or anybody who's there and that's
kind of the crazy thing because he's
like no it's wolverine right he he can
heal from virtually anything and that's
when blade kind of makes a comment even
mutant powers have their limits right
somebody's been eating at him for a long
long time and his body is his healing
factor eventually just gave up and
that's when wolverine comments like you
guys are idiots they knew you were
coming right like they're all waiting
over there right and that's when you end
up finding out that magic is here right
iliana rasputin the person who can
create portals and access you know
access the limbo dimension she
immediately takes out the nana sentinel
she's all said and done there's a
flirkin that kind of comes up on her she
of course ends up getting the flurking
out of the way but what ends up
happening is magic ends up creating a
kind of portal right she literally opens
a portal and brings them to limbo and
that's where black spring is right black
spring is in the realm of limbo and
that's where all the super the infected
superheroes are that's why we haven't
really seen them but there's a lot of
big hitters here right like you've got
silver surfer there's a lot of big name
guys your groot's here and and so on and
it's kind of nuts because it's like okay
like this is what we're dealing with now
i've i've enjoyed the story up to this
point this is where i feel like it kind
of falls short it's a genius idea what
they do and i don't mean to like to take
away and say like it sucks not at all
but i feel like it kind of falls short
but i'm going to leave this to you guys
right because a lot of you guys may
think it's a really really cool concept
and a lot of you guys may think that
it's kind of dumb i'm curious what your
old stance is but once they're brought
to this realm of course susan storm
comes running over like hey mommy's here
daddy's here you know we're gonna
finally bring you into the family like
we're finally gonna gonna bring you into
this this whole thing but frankly it's
like we came here to cure you and that's
when wolverine's like you can't cure
them right they're not your family you
cannot cure these people anymore right
he says the issue with them is that
they're brewed and that's where things
get kind of interesting here right what
we end up finding out or what silver
surfer tells us is that the brood ended
up attacking galactus at some point in
time so a little bit of history here and
this is where i say you know it can kind
of go either way in terms of whether you
think it's a great idea or not a great
idea so the brood and marvel comics are
are largely considered to be one of the
oldest races in existence in the marvel
universe right and the funny thing is
they don't even really come from the
marvel universe they come from elsewhere
we don't really know what universe they
come from but we know they infiltrated
this universe somewhere along the line
but the idea is that the brood are
parasitic in nature right and they're
very similar to like the xenomorphs from
the alien films the difference here is
that where the xenomorphs infect a
person right like you end up you end up
being infected by like a facehugger it
puts an egg inside your body and the egg
hatches and then it busts out of your
stomach right we all we're all familiar
with those scenes the brood actually
take over the host body right so you
would effectively be transformed into a
brood and that's how they procreate the
difference here is that somewhere along
the line the brood infected galactus and
they basically planted their eggs inside
of galactus and so when those versions
of the brood were born they were born as
a kind of cosmic cosmic brood and so
when the various superheroes who
responded to galactus being dead were
infected they were infected by a kind of
brewed rude hybrid of sorts meaning they
keep their physical forms but they kind
of change into something else right
they're basically just kind of driven by
the hunger of galactus is really what
they are so it's very similar to the
original marvel zombies but different in
that way i don't know it's kind of
interesting now where the plot gets a
little thin where you know where the
where the plot thins and it gets a
little you know kind of redundant is
where the response of silver surfer at
least a statement he makes is limbo can
access any universe and the whole
multiverse we want to spread into the
multiverse and kind of consume
everything par for the course with
regards to marvel zombies we saw it in
the original zombies by robert kirkman
uh and we're seeing it here right we're
seeing this the same kind of thing play
out but it's kind of a crazy thing
because where you end up having you know
susan and them you know take it
basically you know taking uh franklin
with the intention of infecting him
finding out why or at least not really
infecting him finding out why it is that
despite being infected he hasn't turned
and then looking to effectively force
him to turn and then utilize the full
totality of his power as one of their
kind peter parker of course begs them to
stop but that's when susan says like why
are you so sad your family's here too
and we're met by the arrival of an
infected mary jane watson and she says
like now we can finally be together
peter like we're going to be together
forever
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the conclusion
of marvel zombies resurrection right
this wraps up the whole thing and what
we do here is we kind of start off a
little bit ago and essentially what's
left of the superhero community right
even just super hero and super villain
community right so you've got miles
morales you've got bucky barnes you got
doctor strange you've got electro right
spider-man villain well-known spider-man
villain you've got these different
characters who are here and seemingly
out of nowhere they're met by the
arrival of spider-man who of course has
valeria richards and franklin richards
in tow so this is during the initial
outbreak here now the truth is that this
is kind of cool and this kind of makes
sense this is where marvel zombies
resurrection could either succeed
incredibly well or fail disastrously so
far the story is not too bad i mean it
definitely needs some work and there's
definitely some expansion that i think
needs to be done in order to make it
make more sense but there's a lot of
great stories that could be told here
right like everything that was going on
during the initial outbreak and that's
why i say i think that marvel zombies
started happening the way that it did as
a direct response to deceased right that
we got the marvel zombies returned one
shot and then we got nothing for like a
year and then we get you know marvel
zombies number one long after deceased
has already kind of done its thing right
and basically told its main story and so
with peter parker and them arriving he
basically begs anybody to save franklin
richards and nobody can right not even
doctor strange right he's like there's
nothing i can do here i can't say
franklin but warlock steps up and says i
can save him but it won't necessarily be
the way that you think and so again
picking back up in the modern day right
now we have peter and the rest of the
heroes who went to the galactus hive
right where galactus basically crash
landed on earth as kind of the first of
the infected so to speak carrying all
the other infected heroes and then
bringing them here and so with with you
know peter encountering mary jane of
course she's kind of beseeching him
telling him hey you know join us that
kind of a thing and then basically in
the middle of nowhere you know when when
uh susan goes to bite franklin this
suddenly phalanx starts emerging out of
franklin richards and the whole shield
and everything of susan storm lets down
and that's what we end up finding out
that the way that franklin lived is that
this is not actually franklin richards
right it is but it's not truly like the
like the true franklin the true franklin
richards has long since been dead right
he died at the very beginning of the
whole thing because he was bitten what
ended up happening is that warlock used
his phain-links ability right so
basically this kind of like
techno-organic virus kind of ability to
basically create a new franklin
richard's body and then the
consciousness of franklin was moved by
doctor strange from his old body into
his new body and so that's why he
doesn't recollect anything that happened
he doesn't recall being bitten or any of
that stuff because he is kind of a holy
new created character the thing about
this is that he's not fully human the
other part of this is that valeria once
she starts to kind of realize the way
things truly are that her family really
can't be saved she does what she has to
do and she basically starts killing them
right she starts killing off ben grimm
and and johnny and and reed and susan
and all them she basically starts
killing them all you know it's you know
and and sucks right because she has to
annihilate her family the other part of
that is that chewie the cat who of
course can swallow huge amounts of stuff
ends up spitting back up a bunch of the
robots that it had previously swallowed
when they were in the machine city and
so it's kind of a you know ad hoc
reinforcements right and things are
happening super fast here and of course
that basically leads to peter accepting
the fact that mary jane is not actually
his girl anymore iliana rasputin tries
to go toe-to-toe with blade and of
course you know she kind of gets the
upper hand on him to a degree of course
doesn't necessarily kill him but when
she goes in for the killing blow
wolverine finally reemerges and then
cuts off the head of ileana rasputin and
so that's when valeria is like we have
to get to the galactus hive right we
have to get up there as fast as we
possibly can and so peter leaves mary
jane behind and once they get to the to
the galactus hive itself or at least as
they try to make their escape nana the
sentinel kind of ends up giving them a
ride but nana isn't really able to make
it as fast as she can right because
she's basically had a whole bunch of
damage done to her systems and so in her
current condition it's the fastest she
can go but it's not working because
everybody's catching up to them right
all these people are traveling as fast
as they possibly can to seize everybody
here and so what ends up happening is
nana actually discharges her arms and
sends the rest of them flying at the
galactus hive and then she's ultimately
destroyed now once they get there the
big question to ask here is what do they
do now that they're in the galactus hive
what do they do in this situation is it
simple is it more difficult like how
does all this work and so what we end up
getting is is valeria basically saying
like i need two minutes and that's when
the silver surfer intervenes and it
makes perfect sense that he would that
the silver surfer you know as a former
herald of galactus would basically
remain inside of galactus right would
just kind of stay there as a kind of
safety safety device and you get this
amazing moment between franklin richards
and the surfer right the franklin
literally uses his warlock abilities and
just sends us like pins a surfer against
the wall and when the server calls his
board he takes the sword of magic of
iliana rasputin the soul sword and cuts
the board in half right and then just
loses it just says like you guys killed
everybody you killed forge you killed
uncle ben you killed uncle johnny you
killed nana you killed everyone and
franklin takes the full totality of the
soul sword and slices silver surfer in
half and basically kills it now one
thing to understand here and i think
it's kind of smart that marvel did this
this is not the full totality of
franklin's powers right he doesn't
really have his reality warping
abilities anymore because seemingly his
abilities were tied to his body now in
all truth it shouldn't work that way
unless you have something like a healing
factor or something along those lines
your powers are not tied to your body
your powers are tied to your mind's
ability to control something that's why
that that bit is important there it's
how you know individuals like the
beyonder that has no true physical form
can still do the kind of things that he
does right the beyonder takes on a
physical form but the beyonder is
essentially just living energy with
somebody like galactus he's the exact
same way if you saw galactus in his true
form he would just be a swirling mass of
energy in a giant purple suit and that
would be it right so franklin's ability
to to do what he can do is not tied to
his physical body so by all standards of
measurement even having his
consciousness transformed or moved to a
new body should still mean that he can
alter reality on a universal scale but
such as it was philip kennedy the guy
writing this story kind of went with the
idea that franklin's ability to utilize
his powers are tied to his physical form
right and so that's why he's not really
able to to use reality warping on a
massive scale at least not that we've
seen now the other part of this of
hilarious plan that what she's doing
here is she's basically using the power
of gambit and that this hand that she
has in her possession was taken by taken
by remy lebeau taken by gambit by forge
himself and that forge would use it as a
kind of source of energy what she's
doing here is literally channeling the
power of gambit into the heart of
galactus and the intention is to
completely and totally destroy it and so
valeria tells franklin get everybody out
of here as fast as you can right the
sword will know what to do the sword
will know how to get them away and so
what it is up doing is whisking away
franklin blade the cat wolf reign you
know everybody here right everybody
who's here spider-man valeria herself
they all get teleported away just as
galactus entire physical form is
destroyed by uh by the hand of of gambit
now here's the funny thing about this is
that technically speaking gambit could
do this gambit could kill galactus and
the reason why is because gambit's
ability is to basically charge up
potential energy to take potential
energy turn it into kinetic energy to
basically take objects that are in rest
and put them in motion exceedingly fast
and to force them to spontaneously
combust there are some limitations
depending on what we're talking about
here but we're also talking about this
particular universe so we don't really
know if gambit in this universe
underwent the same kind of lobotomy
process that he did in the main marvel
universe which reduced his powers the
fact that he's powerful enough to
destroy galactus would seem that that's
not the case that he actually never
underwent that process and there's no
limit to the power that he has the other
part of this though is that gambit's
limit in terms of his ability to destroy
objects is truly limited by his mind
because of the fact that his mind was
altered to restrict how much of his
power he could use and so if you have a
person who can utilize the power of
gambit without any of the blocks that
gambit has in his mind then seemingly
they could destroy galactus right
there's as many questions being left
unanswered here as there are questions
being answered here but galactus in the
entire hive are completely and totally
destroyed right so in effect the heroes
basically won here and so what we end up
doing is picking up a month later with
nana being rebuilt by the combined
efforts of valeria alongside vivian
right the daughter of vision and with uh
with blade actually training franklin on
how to use a sword the question kind of
comes down to what comes next and what
wolverine talks about is actually
reopening the xavier school right
reopening the school and because there's
still mutants out there even though
they're in hiding there's still mutants
out there that still have their powers
and the x-men still need to exist so
it's kind of reforming the team even if
only helping to combat whatever forces
happen to exist out there because not
all of humanity has been destroyed not
all of humanity has been defeated and so
while there are still mutant survivors
there are still human survivors so
there's still room there to create
stories of like you know mutants against
humans and different things like that
but franklin ultimately ends up leaving
right ultimately ends up you know going
back inside the house and heading back
into his room and what we end up finding
out here is that he still has the head
of silver surfer because he has
questions that he's been reading over
the books of charles xavier specifically
in relation to the brood and he asks
every single brood hive has a queen
right so if the brood hive infected
galactus and then in turn galactus was
brought to earth when he infected the
heroes then that means there had to have
been a brood queen on earth so the
question is who's the brood queen right
who's this person that's in charge of
the brood this one individual that
survived and could repopulate and
basically recreate this entire zombie
infection yet again only improve on
where they messed up before and the
response to silver surfer is that she
knows exactly who you are she knows who
you are she knows what it is that all of
you guys did on this earth and the two
of you will meet soon enough and so the
indication here is that the brood queen
is actually carol danvers right the shoe
is infected and she's the one that's
basically kind of running the show so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you guys
are new here to comments to explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and let me know what you guys
thought about marvel zombies down in the
comments section for being honest with
you guys it's a much lackluster story
than the original marvel zombies it's
not nearly as good but uh yeah we're
gonna bring this to an end and i will
catch you all later
peace